Ich hoffe, es hat euch gefallen.
Musik
Untertitelung des ZDF, 2020
hallo ein bisschen länger gepennt
manchmal die musik an und leise eigentlich ja ich war nicht fahrradfahren
Kurz gucken wie warm es eigentlich ist draußen.
11 Grad.
Da hätte ich auf jeden Fall langes Zeug anziehen müssen wenn ich denn Fahrrad fahren gehen
würde.
... Musik ...
Ich mach mal Package Updates, das schadet nie.
Ich glaub ich uninstall VirtualBox wieder, das macht komische Netzwerkdinger.
Wegen gestern beispielsweise auch hier die Internetverbindung, also die aus der VM, aus
VMware nicht, obwohl das ja eigentlich gar nichts mit VirtualBox zu tun haben sollte,
aber VMware dachte die VirtualBox Netzwerkkarte ist das wo es benutzen soll, was Schwachsinn
Package Updates.
Ganz bestimmt nicht. Die Kiste ist aus. Ich würde mich wundern,
wenn da jetzt gerade noch eine Java Fehlermeldung herkommt.
Das ist so high available, selbst wenn man es ausschaltet ist es weiterhin da.
So, Add Package Updates. Gibt es Kernel Updates? Ne, sieht nicht so aus.
Der Kai sagt, er war gestern auf einem Retro-Computing-Fest und hat eine funktionsfähige Magnafox-Odyssee gesehen.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was das überhaupt ist.
Was ist das?
Klingt wie ein Videorekorder oder sowas.
Die erste Spielekonsole.
Okay.
Was jetzt?
Chatgear?
Äh.
Okay.
Hatte ich auch noch nicht.
Aus 1972.
Okay, das ist alt.
Nee, ich bin gerade so gestanden.
Mir geht es heute auch nicht so gut.
Aber das bin ich krank.
Also nicht erkältet oder so.
Nee, nee, nee, nee.
So.
Reboot.
Mal gucken, ob es
neues Jetbrains Gedöns gibt.
Oh!
Ganz viel neues Jetbrains Gedöns.
Update all. Bam.
Dann warten wir noch kurz mit Reboot,
bis der fertig ist.
Ich weiß auch nicht,
wie lange ich heute stream.
Ja,
solange das mit Secureboot
funktioniert.
Ich denke mal,
wird es schon funktionieren.
Und solange ich dann die Tage da fit bin, wo das rauskommt, ansonsten erst danach.
Mal gucken.
Hast du schon die Portal News mitbekommen?
Ich habe mal so ein Preview-Video gesehen für Portal.
Das sah eigentlich ziemlich cool aus mit einem eigenen Editor und sowas.
Oder was meinst du?
Oder meinst du das?
Also es ist deutlich umfangreicher als in 2042.
Was ich sehr nice finde, weil die besten Spielmodi werden wahrscheinlich irgendwelche Modder createn.
wenn sie denn können, also wenn das genug Möglichkeiten bietet.
Es wäre mega, wenn Modder eigene Maps machen können,
aber so weit wird Portal wahrscheinlich nicht gehen.
Die trennen die Server von experimentell und offiziell, um XP-Boosting zu verhindern.
Ja gut, das wundert mich jetzt nicht.
Gab ja in 2042 so Sachen wie fliegt mit dem Heli einfach eine halbe Stunde im Kreis.
Das wäre ja insane. Naja, es gibt ja genug andere Games, wo das funktioniert.
Naja gut, mittlerweile nicht mehr so viele.
Also früher war das relativ normal, dass Spiele, Map Editor und so Zeug mitgeliefert haben.
Relativ normal. COD 4 hatte sowas auch noch.
Gut, von Half-Life 1 und 2 müssen wir gar nicht reden.
Gerade Half-Life 1 hat ja unendlich viele Mods.
Es wurde dann immer seltener.
Wobei ich sagen muss, der beste Boost in Battlefield 2042 am Anfang war ja auf...
Ich habe schon wieder vergessen, wie die Map heißt.
Die Map mit den vielen Hochhäusern.
Wie hieß denn das Ding nochmal?
Seht ihr mal, wie vergesslich man quasi ist und wie unbedeutend die 2042 Maps waren.
Ne, Orbital war das mit der Rakete.
Wie hieß denn das?
Kaleidoskop?
Ne, kann das...
Die Map in der Stadt mit den vielen Hochhäusern.
Kaleidoskop kann das sein?
Die Map mit den vielen Containern, ja.
So, und...
Da konnte man sich ja
aufs Dach legen am Anfang.
Hinter so eine Kiste.
Oder?
Eigentlich war es hinter so eine Klimaanlage.
Weiß nicht, was da auf dem Dach war. Konnte man sich hinlegen
und da unten drunter durchschießen.
Mit einem LMG. Und da konntest du dann quasi
hunderte bots killen und da konntest alles mega schnell leveln. So wir haben rebooted.
Hier können wir alles dicht machen. So, gucken wir mal was auf github so trendet.
Wie ist denn diese 2042? BF2042 Maps.
Cache Yield gar nicht. Warum?
Mal lassen wir kurz gucken welche ich meine.
Gott, ja hier bla blub.
Nein. Nein.
Die meine ich, doch Kalioskop, ja.
Hier.
Da konnte man.
Falls ich da jemand nicht bei Katze offiziell
angeführt habe, falls der jemand nicht rein...
Boosting
BF 2042.
Ja, ich glaube, da sieht man es.
Ja, genau, das meine ich.
Das meine ich.
Da konnte man sich auf dem Dach hinter so eine Klimaanlage legen
und einfach endlos Potts abballern.
Und die konnten nichts machen.
Die waren zu dumm, um die Ecke zu kommen.
Da konntest du alles leveln und...
Man konnte da übrigens auch einfach hoch.
Guck mal, die...
So richtig dumm, oder?
Deswegen ist eigentlich ganz gut, dass die die Server da trennen.
Guckt euch den Scheiß an.
Da hast du in einer halben Stunde alles gelevelt, ey.
High-Skill-Gameplay.
Die Half-Life 1 KI war schlauer
Die Half-Life 1 KI war
Für die damalige Zeit war die
Fast cleverer als in den meisten anderen Games
Da muss ich mal überlegen
In Half-Life 1 konnten die Soldaten quasi sogar
Granaten in die Richtung werfen
Wo sie dich zuletzt gesehen haben
Und haben dann auf der anderen Seite gewartet
Ob du rausgerannt kommst und sowas
Also
Also muss man echt sagen, die waren gar nicht blöd.
Habe ich nie gespielt, aber die Games sehen ja auch schon so aus, als ist die KI dumm.
Aber wisst ihr was ich halt ein bisschen doof finde?
Das Battlefield 6 wieder keinen richtigen Server Browser hat.
Und ja ich weiß es gibt ne Übersicht über Portal Server, aber da muss der erst wieder
über 3 Untermenüs hin.
Das ist halt zack.
Wenn du die Leute quasi trainierst, auf Quickmatch zu drücken.
Das finde ich doof, weil ich fand es eigentlich ganz cool.
Ja, und wisst ihr, was ich...
Also ich habe ja am Anfang Battlelog, ganz am Anfang,
habe ich Battlelog auch etwas gehatet,
weil ich gesagt habe, Alter, warum Browser, warum nicht Ingame?
Aber im Nachhinein betrachtet ist Battlelog eigentlich die schlauste Sache,
die sie da je machen konnten, weil so Sachen wie Friendlist-Management, Party-Invite und dieses ganze Zeug,
das ist halt einfach über eine Webseite und im Browser, ist das viel besser und einfacher zu erledigen,
als irgendwie hakelig über ein Ingame-Menü.
So, und das war eigentlich richtig, richtig gut.
Du konntest Server-Favoriten, du konntest deine History angucken,
du konntest gucken, wo deine Freunde gerade auf dem Server spielen,
du konntest Squads aufmachen.
Das war richtig, richtig gut, ja.
Ich habe es am Anfang auch ein bisschen geflamed,
aber ich bin da relativ schnell draufgekommen.
Das war eigentlich sehr nett.
Man konnte sehen, was für Unlocks hat der im Nix und so.
Das war eigentlich richtig gut.
Verstehe ich gar nicht, warum sie das nicht machen.
Und was halt auch nice war,
dass es halt so persistente Server gab im Endeffekt.
Also du konntest immer auf dem gleichen Server spielen.
Und du kanntest dann irgendwann auch die Leute schon und wusstest, okay, der Server hat ganz sinnige Regeln.
Zum Beispiel, dass nicht 80% Sliper spielen können oder sowas.
Ah.
Ja mal gucken wie es ist.
Warum ist meine Platte eigentlich so voll?
Was soll das?
XK blank für den Sub.
Level die Leute hatten, ja man konnte gucken wer alles auf dem Server ist.
Das war richtig gut, also im Nachhinein betrachtet war Battlelog eigentlich so eines der besten
Sachen, die sie da machen konnten.
Ich habe ja am Anfang auf der Xbox 360 gespielt und da konntest du ja über ein Ingame Menü
joinen.
Konntest aber dir auch deine Sachen und Stats
konntest du dir glaube ich auch im Battlelog angucken.
Aber Serverauswahl und so war halt
über
Ingame-Menü und das war halt auf dem PC viel nicer
mit Battlelog.
Kann man nichts sagen.
Also, das war eine
gute Sache. Battlelog war nice.
Und wisst ihr was ich auch lustig finde in Battlefield 3 und auch in Battlefield 4?
Oder gerade in Battlefield 3, da haben die ja alle paar Monate einen DLC veröffentlicht
mit mehreren Maps drinne und die Maps waren zum größten Teil alle gut.
Und jetzt schaffen sie gefühlt, keine Ahnung, im halben Jahr eine Map.
Fragt man sich auch, wie haben die das damals denn eigentlich gemacht?
Findest du? Warum?
Achso, ja, oder, oder, oder eine Verschwörungstheorie-Vibe.
Weil die sagen ja auch immer, man muss aufwachen.
Und die Verschwörungstheorie-Leute, die Keck-Alu-Leute, die sagen immer,
du musst dich auch mal unabhängig informieren, wacht auf.
Genau.
Das ist auch was, was ich nicht so ganz checke.
Warum ausgerechnet in der heutigen Zeit so Dinger wie Flat Earth
auf einmal mehr zuspruch haben als früher wo ich denke gerade in der heutigen zeit wo du
easy zugang hast alles die anzugucken ausgerechnet heute aber man muss es nicht verstehen ich gucke
ganz gerne immer die die videos von simon denn da das ja immer alles schön die bank und da sind
teilweise schon echt abenteuerliche Sachen
drin. Am besten sind die, die
die Meinung sind, dass
die Erde ist irgendwie nur 10.000 Jahre alt
und
dann erzählen sie dir noch irgendwas
von der Sintflut und
ganz abgedrehtes Zeug.
Magst du das schon was getrunken?
Ja, ich hab schon so ungefähr ein Drittel
von meinem Tee leer.
Oder waren es 6.000 Jahre? Ach, keine Ahnung.
Ganz wirres Zeug.
Mein Discord? Ist das wirklich so?
Ich habe ewig nicht mehr in meinen Discord reingeguckt.
Auf politische Diskussionen habe ich eigentlich keinen Bock.
Du hast letztens ein Video gepostet.
Im Discord. Ja gut, ich habe nicht reingeguckt.
Wieso? Was denn?
So.
Was trendet denn?
Money Printer?
Das ist ja ein
nices Projekt.
Das
können wir wahrscheinlich alle gebrauchen, oder?
Easy Money Printer Turbo.
GUI Framework in Rust.
Du meinst nicht Tauri, oder?
Hast du einen kranken Gamingstuhl
oder eher was ergonomisches? Ich hab was ergonomisches.
Mach mal Ausrufezeichen Stuhl.
Ich glaube, da gibt es sogar einen Link zu.
Lass mal kurz ausprobieren. Wartet mal.
Ausrufezeichen Stuhl.
Ja, guck hier da.
Den hab ich.
Nicht so sehr vom Preis verwirren lassen.
Wenn du ein bisschen suchst im Internet, kriegst du den auch
deutlich günstiger.
Bei Amazon ist es vielleicht ein bisschen
übertrieben teuer.
Also ich glaube, ich habe 1200 Euro bezahlt.
Aber trotzdem muss ich mal überlegen.
Guck mal, der hat auch keine Bewertung auf Amazon.
Muss ich mal überlegen, wie viel man da drauf sitzt und man irgendwie ja auch sein Geld so ein bisschen damit verdient.
Oh shit, Alter, das ist doch ganz schön teuer geworden.
Ich habe 1200 noch was bezahlt.
Keckweight, Alter.
Moment, wir gehen mal zu Google.
Kurz Google.
Muss ich halt überlegen, ob sie
vielleicht doch keine schlechte Idee ist.
Guck mal, 600.
Das ist doch gebraucht, oder?
das ist doch gebraucht. Warum kann man das nicht öffnen?
Das ist gebraucht, ne? Der sieht so gebraucht aus schon. Hier und hat auch ein paar Flecken.
Da steht aber überhaupt nicht dabei. Ah hier Zustand gebraucht, okay.
Ja, aber sowas anscheinend muss man mittlerweile doch so in dem Dreh damit rechnen.
Also ich habe noch 1200 Euro bezahlt, das ist aber auch schon einige Jahre her.
Aber der Stuhl ist immer noch wie neu.
Ja, ich finde schon, dass es den Preis wert ist.
Würde ich mir wieder kaufen.
Ich bin ja auch überhaupt nur auf die...
Hast du das Video vom Krieger gesehen?
Du meinst, dass er so abgenommen hat?
Ein bisschen, ein bisschen habe ich reingeguckt, ja.
Ist richtig dünn geworden.
Massive.
Also was ich an dem Stuhl halt gut finde ist,
du hast...
Also es gibt mehrere Sachen.
Also als erstes muss ich sagen,
der Stuhl ist brutal stabil, ja.
Also du kannst da drauf rum springen,
dich quasi nur an den Armen lehnen, festhalten mit deinem ganzen Gewicht
und das juckt den überhaupt nicht.
Der ist auch, glaube ich, zugelassen bis 250 Kilo oder sowas.
Mal kurz gucken.
Sieht man jetzt hier nicht.
Hier, 200 Kilo Körpergewicht.
Also selbst wenn man richtig
Pipo fett ist
Ist das kein Problem
Mit dem
Wenn man einfach nur 2,50 Meter
Groß ist
Dann ist das auch kein Problem
Was ich halt auch nice
Finde ist
Moment, wir gehen jetzt einfach mal auf die offizielle
Webseite von denen
Was ich auch nice finde ist der Konfigurator.
Was kann man da machen?
Erstmal Placeholder laden.
Ich glaube der Konfigurator konfiguriert nicht richtig.
Liegt das vielleicht der NewBlock?
Der Konfigurator mag nicht.
Der Konfigurator konfiguriert nicht.
Ich mache mal kurz U-Block aus.
Aber der Konfigurator konfiguriert nicht.
Okay, dann machen wir U-Block wieder an.
Ach ne, der hat reloaded.
Okay, der Konfigurator ist gerade broken.
Der funzt nicht.
Aber was ich an dem Stuhl richtig gut finde ist,
ich hoffe man sieht es hier irgendwie.
Okay, hier kann man es glaube ich ganz gut sehen.
Also erstens ist der Stuhl massive stabil.
Ich habe den hier oben mit so einer Kopfstütze noch.
Der ist massive stabil.
Also da tut sich nichts.
Du kannst alles mögliche einstellen.
Vom Druckpunkt, wie leichtgängig die Rückenlehne ist.
kannst sie feststellen, kannst sie locker stellen, kannst sie so stellen, dass sie sich gar nicht bewegt, kannst genau einen Winkel von der Rückenlehne einstellen, Höhe natürlich auch logischerweise, du kannst 3D verstellen, die Armstützen, die kannst du quasi nach oben und unten verstellen, nach links, rechts und nach vorne, hinten und auch nach schräg vorne damit, ja, weil ich habe beispielsweise auch die linkere Armstütze ein bisschen weiter schräg vorne,
als die die die rechte schräg weiter vorne als ja also das ist richtig richtig nice und ansonsten
ist der stuhl einfach sehr bequem da kannst du zwölf stunden auf deinem poppes sitzen und der
tut dir nicht weh wenn man sich überlegt wir verdienen ja alle irgendwo unser geld damit
dass wir lange auf dem arsch vom rechner sitzen dann ist das vielleicht gar keine schlechte
investition und es hält halt genau wie hier das ding hält halt ewig ich habe das sei vor
weiß nicht 2014 oder so ich weiß es gar nicht genau aber so in dem dreh glaube ich und das
ding das ist wie neu also ja und das gute ist du kannst ja noch einzelne teile austauschen
Ja, du musst dir keinen neuen Stuhl kaufen, wenn du ein neues Polster brauchst.
Hast du den vorher getestet im Laden?
Nee, aber warum ich überhaupt auf die Idee gekommen bin, mir den Stuhl zu kaufen, ist, wir hatten den auf der Arbeit.
und daher kannte ich den schon und deswegen habe ich mir gedacht den kaufst du dir privat auch
das heißt ich habe den schon ausprobiert für monate theoretisch jahre sogar da dachte ich
mir okay wenn er auf der arbeit gut ist dann taucht dafür daheim auch hast du ein halloween
ein Kostüm? Ne. Aber das ist bald, gell?
31.
In Gaming-Stühlen.
Ich hatte davor
einen Gaming-Stühl von DXRacer
und nachdem da beim
zu schnellen Aufstehen einfach
die rechte Armlehne aus dem Rahmen
rausgerissen ist.
Ich meine, ich war damals
halt doch deutlich dicker noch.
25 Kilo. Aber ich war jetzt nicht
irgendwie 200 Kilo schwer.
Ich hab da 108
oder so gewogen.
Jetzt wiege ich um die 80.
Und da ist die Lehne einfach rausgerissen.
Da habe ich mir gedacht, okay, das liegt nicht nur am Gewicht,
sondern bestimmt auch daran, dass die Qualität nicht so geil ist.
Dann habe ich mir einfach keinen neuen Gamingstuhl geholt,
sondern hier diesen super massive, teuren, aber bequemen Bürostuhl.
Und den kann ich auch wirklich empfehlen.
Ja, ich werde Battlefield 6 spielen.
Ja, ich weiss, ich weiss, ich weiss.
Nächste Woche kommt Battlefield 6 raus.
Ich glaube schon.
Ja.
So, dann lass uns mal gucken, was trennt er denn auf GitHub so.
Money Printer Turbo.
Ah.
Ach jetzt verstehe ich es, warum das ein Moneyprinter ist
Das Ding generiert
TikTok und YouTube Short Videos
Per AI
Und dann kannst du damit Geld machen
Weil die kriegen dann
Clickbait Titel, Clickbait Zeug generiert
Und spammen die Plattform voll
Und du kannst ein bisschen was verdienen
Okay
ok soll solche videos wenn er also per
erste
ok scheint da richtig gut zu
funktionieren
warum ein chrome auf noch funktionieren
videos vielleicht besser was sie ja die
plattform mit noch mehr scheiße gespammt
in chrome funktioniert ok solche sachen
werden dann da. Generated.
Da kannst du
Fake-Travel-Vlogs
und so machen.
Das hat die Welt gebraucht.
Es ist quasi eine Mischung aus AI
und
Stock-Footage, oder was?
Was machen die denn da?
keck business
da wird money geprintet
ok also man kann damit
shit content generieren
in der hoffnung es gucken sich
ne handvoll leute an
und
du verdienst damit geld
ey die plattform
werden ja so mit KI-Shit.
Ja, das ist Langeweile pur.
Deswegen werden sie auch noch eine Handvoll Aufrufe kriegen.
Die Plattformen werden so vollgespammt
mit KI-Shit, Mann.
Was, Diabetes?
Wie jetzt?
Was hat das jetzt alles
mit Diabetes zu tun gehabt?
Ah ja, okay, Money Printer Turbo.
AI, der hat natürlich 45.630 Sterne.
Die AI-Grills, ja.
Also, du kannst sicherlich mit gut gemachtem AI-Content Klicks baiten und damit auch Geld verdienen, gehe ich mal von aus.
Wie ist das eigentlich? Verdient man mit YouTube Shorts wirklich was?
Also, wie ist da das Payment-Model? Ich habe mir das nie angeguckt.
Ich als krasser YouTube-Influencer sollte das vielleicht wissen, aber ich habe keine Ahnung.
Money-Klitsch, ja.
Ja, da brauchst du erstmal ein Cluster mit 8 Grafikkarten drin wahrscheinlich.
Dann kannst du den ganzen Tag TikTok, YouTube und was auch sonst noch für Plattformen voll scheißen mit Shorts.
Mit AI-generated Shorts.
Ja, natürlich, natürlich.
Komische Ref-Links und so brauchst du auch alles.
1 bis 6 Cent pro 1000 Views.
Okay, da musst du aber wirklich, wirklich viel hochladen für die Handvoll Aufrufe, die du da kriegst.
Erzählst du von N8N? Wir gucken uns gleich ein Fireship-Video dazu an.
Ich hab das irgendwann, glaube ich.
Das ist so ein Open Source, self-hosted, if...
Also hier, gibt's das eigentlich noch?
If...
Ja, gibt's noch.
So eine Automation-Plattform.
Ich glaube ich habe das mal im Docker-Container gestartet
Bei mir lokal, wusste nicht was ich damit machen soll
Und habe es wieder gelöscht
Das wird noch schlimmer in Zukunft
Du meinst der ganze AI-Generated-Content
Tja
Gibt ja auch die Theorie
Dass AI immer dümmer wird
Aber wundert mich auch nicht, wenn AI immer dümmer wird
Weil AI
Trainiert es
Teilweise mittlerweile wahrscheinlich von AI-Generierten-Inhalten
Und von
Dummem Zeug
also wird mich nicht wundern wenn er immer dümmer wird
okay was gibt es denn hier sonst noch
domain specific language gpu cpu accelerators kernels okay das ist zu
high iq für mich aber es ist das gibt mir auch next cloud trendet warum
trendet ausgerechnet jetzt
Nextcloud?
Gab es da eine neue Version?
Oder wie? Oder was? Ah, 32
gab es. Okay.
Es gab Version 32.
Ich bin
ehrlich gesagt nicht geneigt,
das auszuprobieren. Wir gucken einfach
nochmal schnell, was sich da
getan hat, weil
mich nervt Nextcloud.
Es ist so ein
aufgeblasenes
Ding mit
gefühlt an jeder Ecke unfertigem Zeug.
Also, ihr wisst, ich bin kein großer
Nextcloud-Fan. Gibt's da vielleicht
auch eine ordentliche News
dazu und nicht sowas da?
Gucken wir mal bei News.
Da gibt's auch schon was.
Da gibt's auch schon was mit Beheise.
Okay.
Die digitale
Souveränität. Da haben sie jetzt wieder ein Wort für.
Ja, anscheinend gibt es dazu keinen.
Das stimmt überhaupt nicht, AI.
Nextcloud32 ist raus.
Gibt es da ordentliche Release-Ankündigungen oder so?
So, hallo, Nextcloud32 ist raus und...
und 25 ich keine ahnung kein bock wird sie nicht ausprobieren
also ich nutze nextcloud für so gut wie gar nichts das einzige warum ich noch eine uralte
next cloud instanz bei mir laufen habe ist ich habe da irgendwann mal meine
ganzen kontakte drin eingefügt mit card da und da gucke ich ab und zu noch rein
ja aber ansonsten verwende ich next cloud für nix und halte da auch
möglichst abstand von
So was haben wir denn sonst hier noch schönes?
Cloud, Cloud, Cloud, Cloud, Agent SDAI, fuck you code!
Was ist das?
Irgendwas China-Chinesen-mäßiges.
Legacy Mess Detector.
Assesses the legacy mess level of your code.
ein output beautiful report ok ok china chinesen kram das muss man mal kurz
translate erstmal kurz übersetzen translate ok remember this command fuck you code
Maxi und Code less awful. Ein Analyse Tool, das shitty Code erkennt. Okay und sagt uns dann auf
kekw Art wie schlecht das ist. Multi language support. Go javascript, Python, Java, C++,
Shit Mountain Index
Okay, gibt es da auch ein Beispiel für?
Aha
Hat aber fast 5000 Sterne
Die meisten Leute
Die an so einer Codebase arbeiten
Mit ganz viel Fuck You Code
wissen es wahrscheinlich auch so.
Open Pilot.
Ah, ich dachte schon,
das ist irgendwie Co-Pilot, aber AI-Zeug, ja.
AI.
Driver Assistant.
Ein Open-Source-autonomes Fahr-Dings.
Wie soll man sich das vorstellen?
Kann ich das dann auf meinen Fiat flashen
und er fährt von alleine?
Eher nicht, oder?
Das wär's.
das wäre es irgendein random irgendein random github projekt curl pipe bash auf
meinem fiat installieren das ding fährt los
ich auch das werden dann unterstützt
ach von dem ist das
Woher weiß ich denn...
Woher weiß ich denn, was supported...
Okay, supported cars.
Audi.
Kein Fiat, Leute.
Keine Fiat supported.
Siehste?
Kann ich schon mal nicht...
Kann ich schon mal nicht mein Fiat automatisch fahren lassen.
Ich weiß auch gar nicht, ob ich mein Fiat automatisch fahren lassen will, ehrlich gesagt.
Ich glaube, das ist in Deutschland auch rechtlich problematisch, oder?
wenn man sein auto autonom fahren lässt und irgendwas passiert
na gut da bist du halt dran schuld so wie wenn du selbst gefahren wärst aber ich könnte mir
vorstellen das ist das mit dem autonomen fahrenden auto gar nicht auf die straße in deutschland
keine ahnung
Ja, blinken ist hinter Paywall.
Ne, aber das ist ja alles open.
Developer Roadmap. Aha.
Was kriegen wir denn da geroadmappt?
Roadmap.sh
Roadmap für...
skill based roadmap c++ ok passt mal auf gucken wir uns jetzt an step by step
guide to be common sie plus plus developer in 2025 da bin ich ja mal
gespannt
aha install c++
Bitwise Operators, Functions Operators.
Äh.
Warum ist da ein Häkchen dran?
Das braucht man, dass man das nicht mehr braucht, oder?
Bigpointers benutzt man immer.
Okay, was ist ein Diamond Interface?
Okay, Multi-Inheritance.
Im Prinzip beschreiben sie hier einfach nur
alle C++ Features,
die man nacheinander lernen soll.
Okay, naja, nein.
Und es ist halt auch ganz viel Shit dabei, ne?
Weil es ist halt C++.
Dann Shit kaum zu überbieten.
Wisst ihr, was mir auch letztens
in C++ aufgefallen ist, was ich nicht checke?
Ihr seid ja so schlau, Chat.
Muss ich euch mal was fragen.
So, also.
Man kann in C++, das wird jetzt kein C++-Rand, ich glaube, das geht schnell.
Also, man kann in C++ ja eine Funktion anlegen.
So, also, sagen wir jetzt mal hier.
Void, blub.
So, haben wir eine Funktion.
Jetzt kann man den Return-Type dieser Funktion so deklarieren, wie man das eigentlich schon seit Jahrhunderten gemacht hat.
So. Was es jetzt auch in C++ gibt, ist, dass man so machen kann. Auto und dann, genau, hier. Und dann int. Warum? Warum? Warum sollte ich das machen?
Also erstens, warum ist das erlaubt?
Und warum?
Ich verstehe den Sinn davon nicht
Wo ist der Sinn?
Also das hat bestimmt irgendeinen Hintergrund, warum es das gibt
Aber ich check's nicht
Warum sollte ich hier vorne Auto schreiben und da hinten den Return-Type
Anstatt einfach hier vorne den Return-Type hinzuschreiben und das wegzulassen?
Kannst vielleicht zwei Rückgabe-Typen mit Auto bestimmen.
Ja, da müsste ich aber hier hinten auch zwei angeben.
Ja, also ich könnte jetzt hier sagen, keine Ahnung, if.
Hier true.
Das ist natürlich bescheuert.
Return 1.
So, dann können wir sagen, wenn nicht, dann return 1.1 oder so.
Es wird nie ausgeführt.
Das kann man auch zu int-Dingsen oder String.
So, bam.
Das geht nicht, weil es nicht kompatibel zu int.
Ich habe legit absolut keine Ahnung, warum das ein Ding ist.
Warum man das hier mehrfach angeben kann.
Also wenn es vom Chat auch keiner weiß, dann...
Das kommt nicht von C.
Das ist nicht gültige C-Syntax.
Ich dachte vielleicht...
Hire Q im Chat, ihr wisst das vielleicht.
Aber ist das auch nicht das ist so ein ding wo ich mir auch warum ist das überhaupt so ein ding ist bestimmt eine
Expressivität findet dass hier irgendjemand mehr expressive als so jetzt war jetzt mal ernsthaft
guckte mal chat
das versus das
Was ist da mehr expressive chat
1 versus 2
Das da oder das da?
Also ich sage eindeutig das da.
Weil es ein Syntax ist, den man seit 150 Jahren schon kennt.
Und irgendwie auch sofort klar ist.
Ich meine, das kann dir erlauben, den Return-Typ von Parametern abhängig zu machen.
äh
chat gpt ok
beides meint das gleiche ding
ja gut
schön das es zwei verschiedene varianten in c++
wieder für das gleiche gibt
gibt es ja noch nicht genug
however
lies in style
context in how c++ parser ports more complex
ok also auch keine gescheite antwort
von chat gpt
Okay, pass mal auf, wir fragen jetzt ChatGPT nochmal.
ChatGPT.
Versus.
Bam.
Semantically equivalent.
Take so or transint.
Syntax and style.
Traditional Syntax
Classic Style
Easy to Read
Okay, jetzt bin ich mal gespannt
was der, okay, wenn
das der Classic Style Easy to Read ist
dann bin ich mal echt gespannt, warum man eine neue Syntax
braucht
Okay, das gibt es in C++
Known as a Trailing Return Type
Useful
Okay
The return type depends on
complex template expressions
You're using type deduction but need to specify the type explicitly.
Moment, schließt sich das nicht aus?
You're working with lambda expressions or generic programming.
Okay, das ist irgendwelcher Kram für Templates anscheinend.
For templated code.
example okay ist okay
Hä?
ok c++ template template ich weiß noch nicht was das überhaupt macht
bedeutet das dann dass der return type
das ist doch was überhaupt legit
also wenn t und u nen float ist dann ist der return type nen float
wenn t und u nen int ist dann ist der return type int
Okay, und ich gehe mal davon aus
Dass man dieses komische Gedöns hier
Nicht vorne hinschreiben kann
Liegt daran, weil der C++ Parser
Das nicht auf die Reihe kriegt
Da vorne was mit Klammern und Namen
Okay, also es ist irgendein Ding
Für Templates anscheinend
Aber sollte das
Auto nicht automatisch checken
Return T plus U
Warum muss ich dem das explizit sagen
egal was auch immer c++
heißt zu 99 prozent braucht man es wahrscheinlich nicht
okay haben haben die auch eine roadmap für.net
asp.net core jetzt bin mal gespannt was man da lernen soll in der roadmap der ai tutor
MonkaS, geh mal weg.
Was lernt man hier?
Shit.
Shit Hub.
Shit Lab.
Und Bitbucket.
Gut, das macht natürlich Sinn.
Warum sind das Häkchen?
Warum sind da Häkchen schon dran?
Man kann es auch nicht mal anklicken.
Fehler nämlich.
Man soll sich...
Ach ne, das ist was man...
Basics.
C Sharp.
Database, SQL Basics
RepoDB
Ich weiß nicht mal, was RepoDB ist
N-Hibernate, what the fuck
Niemand benutzt N-Hibernate
Wo ist EF Core, Leute
Wo ist EF Core
Das Wichtigste fehlt
Was ist das für eine Roadmap
Niemand benutzt
Okay, Dapper benutzen manche noch, ja
Aber wo ist EF Core
Das Wichtigste, ach Moment, da ist es doch
Manchmal muss man auch die Augen aufmachen, Alter.
Da ist es doch.
Okay.
Ja, dann lass ich es mir gefallen.
Ach so, das hier ist must have und das ist optional.
Okay, dann lass ich es mir auch...
Okay.
Optional.
Okay, das ist quasi Pflicht und das ist optional.
Ja, okay, dann macht es Sinn.
Dann habe ich nichts gesagt.
Dann ist die Roadmap doch okay.
Code First Migration.
Man braucht keine Datenbank Migrations.
Man löscht einfach immer die Datenbank und lässt sie neu anlegen beim Start.
Easy.
Wer braucht schon Persistenz?
doch blau ist quasi
Pflicht insofern, dass das ist, was der
Roadmap-Ersteller empfehlen würde
zu lernen
deswegen hat C-Sharp auch ein blaues Häkchen
und C-Sharp ist ja nur wirklich Pflicht
also der ist der Meinung, das sollte man machen
so sieht also aus okay serie log serie log würde ich auch empfehlen anstatt n log search engines
dynamo db jetzt wollen sie aber wissen postgres ganz ehrlich postgres scheiß auf sql server und
mongo db und gedöns einfach postgres für alles ich würde sagen es kühlt und
postgres damit hat man alles was man braucht zu 99 prozent
fql ja hat nichts wenn man es mal gesehen hat haben wir auch schon im
stream gemacht
er war für was auto da ist weiß ich ich mein ich habe mich gefragt was der sinn ist warum
eine funktion so definiert also für auto da ist weiß ich aber mich ging es explizit darum
warum man auto macht und dann die return karte an gibt anstatt den return von hin zu schreiben
war nicht so schlecht hier die roadmap wünsche ich ganz gut ja razor braucht keiner einer keine
kleinen zeit dort nettes von arsch meiner meinung nach auch blazer wir juckt nicht auch gar nicht
übel developer roadmap projekte hat ja auch nur 339 1554 sterne das ist aber
ordentlich oder
das ist aber echt ich glaube ich habe noch nie ein projekt mit mehr sterne
gesehen es gibt bestimmt aber was das ist das ist echt viel das ist viel
das haben wir letzten zugegeben okay ich habe nichts gesagt das hat mehr das hat
mehr das hat 367.000 oder router polo bietet 70 sterne moment man trennt mit 70 sterne könnte
der fiat champ fast schon trennten platz sechs auf most stars okay gibt es wirklich nicht viel
bischelt rendet a blockchain okay ja das ist das nächste wenn es nicht ist dann ist es blockchain
direktus hört sich fast schon ein bisschen unanständig an becken
for all your projects turn your db internet braunmann jetzt wissen wir bescheid was so
trenden auf geht ab was trinken
C++ haben wir doch die letzten drei Streams
vorletzten drei Streams gemacht
und auch heute Morgen
haben wir uns schon eine C++ Roadmap angeguckt
und C++ gerantet
schaust du ab und zu noch Stellenangebote an
ja, müssen wir echt
Das ist nur gut. Das müssen wir unbedingt mal wieder machen.
Unbedingt haben wir schon ewig nicht mehr gemacht.
Massive.
Muss man unbedingt machen.
Ich denke, wir hätten schon mal wieder richtig Bock drauf.
So, wir gucken jetzt mal ein Video.
Weil der Chat jetzt schon zigmal nach N8N gefragt hat.
Wie spricht man es eigentlich aus?
Knighten
Wo gibt es die Roadmap zu sehen?
Hatten wir doch hier gerade.
Roadmap.sh
Und dann für C++ Developers.
Was gab es da noch?
Habe ich gerade nichts gesehen.
Backend Roadmap
Okay, JavaScript
Achso, ne Feature Roadmap
Ne, ne, ne, ne
Feature Roadmap, da dreh ich durch bei
Max
Denkst du die Junginformatikors
Haben noch ne Chance
Ne müde Mark zu verdienen wegen KI, ja klar
Mach dir keine Gedanken
Oder besser gesagt, mach dir nicht zu viele Gedanken
wegen KI.
KI wird vor allem für sehr viel
generierten Shit sorgen noch die nächsten Jahre.
Man sollte es nicht ganz ignorieren,
weil das kann schon echt praktisch sein.
Ja, also ich habe in letzter Zeit
auch oft, gerade wenn ich
C++ Microcontroller Zeug
gebastelt habe, mal KI gefragt,
kann man das nicht noch moderner und schöner und so
machen, da sind manchmal ein paar ganz gute Tipps dabei.
Ja,
oder auch für irgendwelche Kubernetes-Ressourcen
oder YAML-Syntax-Checks
und sowas. Man sollte es nicht ignorieren.
Das kann einem schon helfen, aber
es wird nicht deinen Arbeitsplatz
komplett ersetzen.
Ich habe keine Ahnung,
ob das so ist. Vielleicht.
Ja, beides ist,
beides geht klar. Es wächst
halt auch immer mehr zusammen.
Das merkt man schon eindeutig die letzten
zehn Jahre über schon.
dass Physio und AE immer
ähnlicher werden.
Von den Themen. Oder immer ähnlicher,
vielleicht verkehrt, immer mehr Überschneidungen haben.
Ja.
Das ist ein guter Spruch.
Ist es laut genug?
Gen Z Boss in a Mini!
OKS.
Jan Oberhauser!
Sieht ein bisschen aus auf den ersten Blick wie Node-RED, oder?
So minimal.
So mit diesen Kästchen.
Lass mich raten, er macht irgendwelche AI-Geschichten und zufällig ist das Video von Hostinger gesponsert.
Meint ihr eigentlich, Fireship hat seine Videos mittlerweile zum größten Teil AI automatisiert?
Ja.
Man könnte das einfach aber auch in GitHub Actions machen, ne?
Endless, but the crazy thing is that all this can be accomplished without writing a single line of code.
Instead, you diagram everything in a flowchart-style editor that makes the logic so clear that any non-technical person can approach it.
And what's even more crazy is that you can unlock all this power in 5 seconds by simply running npx n8n from your terminal right now.
After a few seconds, that'll bring up this beautiful UI where you can start building automation workflows.
A UI that was built with Vue.js, by the way.
Wir können es auf Localhost spielen, aber wenn du ernsthaft bist, willst du einen echten Server, den du hostest.
Das ist ein ernsthaftes Kanal, also heute hosten wir es für nur ein paar Dollar pro Monat auf Hostinger.
Okay, das ist Sponsor von heute's Video.
... der Sponsor von heute's Video.
Wie ich es wusste.
Sie sind berühmt, für die Verfügung von Linux-basierten virtuellen privaten Servern,
um alle deine Apps zu hosten, ohne große Cloud-Providern zu brauchen.
Und es ist ein guter Ort, um unsere eigene private N8N-App zu starten.
Und wir können das durch das Selectionen eines neuen VPS und einer Region, in der wir es hosten.
Von dort können wir ein Baselinex-System und manuell N8N installieren, aber ein viel einfacherer Ansatz ist, ihr Pre-Built-Template zu nutzen.
Es funktioniert mit Ubuntu als Operationssystem mit N8N bereit, aus der Box zu gehen.
Wähle eine Passworte, dann wähle einen Plan für nur 5 Dollar pro Monat.
Und wenn du zu schlecht bist, um das zu erlauben, dann benutze auch den Code Fireship, um noch mehr Geld zu sparen.
Ein paar Minuten später haben wir nun Zugang zu der VPS-Management-Systeme auf dem Dashboard.
Wir könnten SSH in den Server einstellen, um es zu managen, aber es gibt keine Bedürfnisse.
Wir können einfach auf diesen Button klicken, um direkt zu N8N zu gehen.
Sobald ihr hier seid, könnt ihr euch vielleicht fragen, was ihr nächstes Mal macht.
In meiner Meinung, die ersten Dinge, die ihr anschauen wollt, sind die Template.
Wie dieses hier, das AI-Viral-Videos mit NanoBanana und VO3.
und dann alles auf Social Media mit Plotato teilen.
Die echten Workflows sind nur JSON-basiert,
oder weil wir jetzt einen N8n-Instanz erzeugt haben,
können wir dieses Template direkt in unser eigenes Projekt importieren.
Dieser ist ein bisschen zu verrückt für mich,
also bauen wir einen neuen von Anfang an.
Auf dem Dashboard haben wir die Option, hier einen neuen Node zu erstellen.
Und der erste Art von Node, den ihr erstellen könnt, ist ein Art von Trigger.
Es könnte manuell oder auf einem Schedule getriggert werden,
aber in vielen Fällen möchtet ihr einen Art von dritten-Party-App verbinden.
Das ist aber cool, dass das Out of the Box so viel schon unterstützt.
Ich weiß, wenn meine Frau mir dieses Emoji schickt, dass ich etwas wirklich schlecht gemacht habe.
Ich kann diese Daten in diesem Konditionalstatement durch die String-Option und den Container nutzen.
Und jetzt, wenn ich ein Messe mit diesem Emoji bekomme, kann ich ein paar Code runtern.
Am wichtigsten, der erste Weg, um einen domestischen Versuch zu lösen, ist, Blumen zu bestellen.
Leider gibt es keine built-in dritten-Party-Apps, die das tun können, so weit ich weiß.
Aber wir können auch hier eine Node erstellen, um irgendeinen arbitrauten Code zu runtern oder einen dritten-Party-API zu starten.
Ich kenne einen Mann, der eine Flowers-API hat, also werden wir sie einfach nutzen, um
die Flowers für eine immediate Deliverie zu bestellen.
Das ist getan, aber es ist nicht genug.
Wir müssen auch eine Entschuldigung schicken.
Nun, ich habe keine Ahnung, was ich falsch gemacht habe, weil ich meine Weibensmessage nicht gelesen habe.
Jetzt pass auf, das wird jetzt AI generiert.
Aber glücklich sind wir, dass wir mit AI umgehen können.
Wir werden einen neuen AI-Agent-Node kreieren und es mit einem customen Prompt geben, um es
eine Entschuldigung zu generieren.
Wir können es sogar mit Daten aus den vorherigen Punkten im Workflow, wie meine Weibensmessage,
um den Prompt dynamisch zu customisieren.
In der Anwendung der AI-Agent-Node
können wir uns auch die Modelle, die wir wollen,
und die Daten für die Erinnerung
und die Tools für den Modell-Kontext-Protokoll.
Aber jetzt, dass wir eine Entschuldigung haben,
brauchen wir einen Weg, sie zu senden.
Ich könnte das mit einem Telegram-Message machen,
aber ich würde lieber dem Welt, was ein guter Mann ich bin,
mit dem Tweeten auf X publik sein.
Das ist ein sicherer Weg, um eine domästige Diskussion zu lösen,
aber nur in der Lage,
wollen wir auch die ganze Interaktion auf Google Sheets aufschreiben,
Das kann in Zukunft in Geheimdiensten kommen.
Aber es gibt so viel mehr, was wir hier tun können, wenn es um ein Software-as-a-Service-Business geht.
Also ich finde das richtig cool, wie viel da eingebaut ist schon. Das hat was.
Ja, so einen wirklichen Anwendungsfall habe ich jetzt auch nicht.
Also mach das mal gut, Nentor.
Es ist mind-blowing, dass wir hier auf einem 5-Dollar-VPS-Business voll Kontrolle haben.
Ein riesiges Dankeschön an...
Am besten wäre es natürlich, wenn seine Frau da per AI auch darauf antwortet, ja.
Ich dachte, wir sehen jetzt noch, wie es funktioniert.
Wahrscheinlich.
Was verdient ein Wiesenkellner?
Wahrscheinlich viel zu wenig für den ganzen Scheiß, den man sich da geben muss.
Oder man im Zweifelsfall noch aus Versehen angekotzt wird.
Bitte N8N streamen.
Ich weiß nicht, was ich damit machen soll.
Können das echt mal ausprobieren.
Das habe ich sogar hier schon eingetragen.
Wobei, die Liste ist ja eher Append Only, habe ich das Gefühl.
Da kommt ja kaum was raus.
Ich wusste gar nicht, dass der noch Videos macht.
Jetzt ist mir eben auch gerade eins aufgeploppt.
Der Network Chuck.
Das kann ich mir nicht angucken.
Jetzt mal so ein kleines Rechnungseingangsworkflow nachstellen.
Da müsste ja, die meisten Rechnungen kriege ich ja noch als Post, als Papier.
Da müsste ich quasi scannen, OCR und so alles.
Nee, ich finde Network Chuck nicht so prickelnd irgendwie.
Aperless.
Ja, da bin ich zu faul für.
Ich kenne mich.
Ist ja nicht so, als hätte ich so Dinge nicht schon mal ausprobiert.
Ich kenne mich, aber ich richte das ein und bin dann voll motiviert.
scannt drei dinge ein und benutzt nie wieder
workflow für die ganzen issues in fiat champ die mit AI schließen lassen
ne ne die fass ich nicht an
wie viele issues haben wir eigentlich mittlerweile
was ist denn die antwort da drauf
It magically started working for me.
Fiat Champ seems to be abandoned.
Was?
Guck mal, hier gibt es
ein Fiat Champ Fork.
Der hat sogar meine Readme
ein bisschen geforkt.
Aber das ist auch seit drei Monaten nichts mehr passiert.
Moment, der hat das in Python
rewriten
rewritten
das heißt es ist jetzt eine echte homo system integration
vielleicht machen wir irgendwann mal mit dem
vm champ
ich bin mir nicht sicher ob der vm champ
der richtige ansatz war
Ich glaube es wäre viel cooler ohne Lib wird direkt mit Kuemu.
Weil Lib wird ist irgendwie abfuck.
Doch reines Kuemu only wäre besser.
Wolle, danke für den Moment.
Da gab es, da gibt es offene Pull-Requests.
Was ist da los?
Tatsächlich, zwei Stück.
ich habe ja schon pläne für also ich habe schon einige dinge die ich gerne
einbauen würde zum beispiel würde ich dem ding gerne
eine eigene web interface verpassen zum konfigurieren weil das über home
muss das doch schon ein bisschen abartig ist.
Und auch mehr als ein Auto unterstützen.
Aber ich bin irgendwie einfach zu faul gewesen bisher.
Zu wenig Motivation.
So, was können wir uns jetzt angucken?
Das ist so kompliziert.
War damals der Internetzugang.
Okay, das scrollen wir mal kurz drüber.
Ich gucke so altes Zeug gerne.
Das Internet.
1999.
Da hatte ich schon DSL.
Ich bin mal gespannt,
ob sie hier jetzt was mit DSL
oder nur
Modem und so Zeug
zeigen.
Ich hatte einen der ersten,
das habe ich glaube ich schon hundertmal erzählt,
ich war einer der ersten in Hanau damals,
der DSL hatte.
Und das war ein Riesenakt.
Die haben über ein halbes Jahr Verspätung
gehabt mit DSL.
Und
mein Vater hatte
damals die Durchwahl zum hessischen Telekom-Chef.
Nicht, dass ich jetzt Mist
erzähle. Lasst uns mal nachgucken. DSL
in Deutschland. Nicht, dass ich
jetzt wirklich Mist erzähle.
Die ersten Anschlüsse konnten ab 1. Juni in Frankfurt am Main haben.
Also wisst ihr, warum ich mich da dran erinnern kann?
Weil ich hab damit Counter-Strike gespielt.
Und Half-Life-Mods und sowas online.
Und das passt einfach 99-2000 rum.
Und ich war definitiv noch ganz normal in der Schule.
Das muss doch in dem Dreh gewesen sein.
Wir fragen einfach mal.
Seit wann gab es in Hanau TDSL?
Das wird keine AI der...
Was ist denn jetzt los?
Hä?
Habe ich meine...
Was zum...
Ähm, das wird keine AI wissen.
Wir fragen aber trotzdem mal ChatGPT, ob es das weiß.
Ich konnte... Wie?
Moment.
Das dichtet sich nicht irgendwas hinzu?
der sagt, der weiß es nicht.
Was ist mit Chat-GPT los?
Konnte keine seriöse Quelle finden,
die exakt seit wann TDSNH noch 5 war.
Was sich feststellen lässt,
Start-Knowledge,
ja, guck mal, 58 Städte.
Ja.
möchtest du das ja
konnte keine definitiv die exakt dokument in welchem jahr ein paar hinweise
vds led das juckt nicht wirklich
ja
Also ich bin mir relativ sicher, dass ich das
1999 hatte.
Und der Beitrag ist von
1999. Welche Netball?
U-Block Origin Lite.
Weil ja in Chrome U-Block Origin
immer funktioniert. Aber in Firefox
verwende ich natürlich noch U-Block Origin.
Wie viele Tabs? Das sind doch nicht viele Tabs.
Das sind viele Tabs.
Ich habe alternativ hier noch ein paar Tabs.
Also ich denke so
um die 100 Tabs werden wir gerade offen haben.
So, ich bin mal gespannt,
ob die was zu Modem oder
DSL schon erzählen.
Mal gucken, ob der Beitrag überhaupt was taugt.
Wir gucken trotzdem mal rein.
Ich gucke gerne so alten Shit.
Boah.
Das war doch alles
so seriös damals.
Live!
Ähm, gibt's nicht einen der Computer-Club-Leute, der heute sogar noch auf YouTube sowas macht?
Bilde ich mir ein.
Aber nicht der.
Ja.
Manche fragen sich, ob sie einen neuen Rechner haben müssen.
Was muss ich eigentlich dazu haben? Muss ich alles neu kaufen dazu?
Wir wollen mal versuchen, in dieser Sendung Antworten darauf zu geben.
Da ist auch Gerd Pasch. Gibt es was Neues in dieser Woche?
Ja.
Der sieht ja mal so richtig 90er aus, der Typ.
Spielmesse und da Konsolen, 128 Bit, auch Internetanschlussfähig.
Okay, wir werden mehr davon hören.
Was war das? PS2 und Dreamcast oder was?
Die können natürlich wieder mit uns in Verbindung treten.
über unsere elektronischen medien michael mengehausen von pop ross ja
streamen wir machen ja seit drei sendungen einen live stream von uns
moment was machen die 1999 live stream von sendung sie können sich also im
internet das ganze sich anschauen die waren ja mal richtig früh dabei
auf welcher seite hat man damals live streamt wahrscheinlich auf der eigenen
webseite da musstest du mit real player dich noch connecten unsere adresse www
punkt wdr punkt slash tv slash computerclub damals war schon die
zukunft weitergeleitet zu unserem stream partner und wann kann man das ganze sich
noch mal anschauen ja also die sendung von heute außer dass
jetzt halt live gestreamt wird man kann sich jetzt angucken und ab heute abend
wird sie auch im internet verfügbar sein da kann sich jeder noch mal so als video auf der vorgänger
der mediathek okay man kann sich auch die letzten sendungen kann sich noch anschauen so bitte ist es
wieder dabei bitte xxp sternchen wie der raute die alte nummer und uns doch fragen schicken oder auch
antworten zu fragen die flasche ja da sehen wir schon einmal so zu erwähnen
wer das nicht kennt btx ist quasi so eine art videotext von der telekom
gewesen ist so ein interaktiver video ist so ein bisschen wie interaktiver
videotext von der telekom
es war quasi so die internet die internet alternative von der telekom es
hat dann dass das gab es nicht so lang und hat dann auch keiner mehr benutzt
Das kannst du dir so ein bisschen wie eine Mischung aus Internet und Videotext vorstellen.
Warte mal.
BTX Telekom.
Bildschirmtext.
Bilder.
Ja, so sah das aus.
Das war quasi ein Browser, der aussah wie Videotext im Browser.
Ne, Browser war es ja nicht, es war das eigene Client.
Ja, es war ein bisschen wie vernetzter interaktiver Videotext.
Sieht auch ein bisschen aus wie Videotext, ne?
Bildschirmtext, BTX, in der Schweiz Videotext.
War ein Online-Videotext-System.
1983 von der Bundespost wurde das noch eingeführt.
Und wurde eingestellt 2007.
Ja.
Das war ganz schön lang am Start, oder?
25 Jahre fast.
Aber wisst ihr, was ich cool finde daran?
Wir waren mal eine Zeit lang technisch voll vorne mit dabei.
Haben es dann aber irgendwie 30 Jahre lang verkackt.
Das war voll Pleading Edge Hightech damals.
Guck mal, 1983.
Ja, also.
Ja, und so sah das damals aus.
Ja, gucken wir mal weiter.
Weiß ich nicht, ob dann die CDU kam. Die war doch vorher auch schon am Start.
Eine Menge ISDN-Modems und Dinge werden wir gleich drauf eingehen.
Oh, das ist eine Fritz-Box. Oh, eine Fritz-Card war es ja damals noch.
Mark Müller, E-Mails aus dem Internet. Hier unsere Adresse cconline.wdr.de.
Ich frage mich, was passiert, wenn man da heute hinschreibt noch?
Sind schon welche da?
Doch, sind schon welche da und ich denke mal, dass
ich hoffe zumindest, dass sie auch dann
zur Zufriedenheit beantwortet werden. Ja, vielleicht können wir sie
gar nicht beantworten. Sind sie nicht so speziell, hoffe ich.
Nö, so speziell sind sie nicht.
Und wir haben wieder ein Faxgerät angeschlossen.
Dennis, du wartest auf die Faxe.
Natürlich, was sonst?
Ey, das war aber damals voll
angesagt noch, Fax.
Man darf nicht vergessen, dass
am Anfang zu Corona
wurden ja wirklich noch Sachen
also Sachen
abgetippt, per Fax geschickt,
auf der anderen Seite wieder eingetippt
und sowas.
Wir haben eine neue Nummer, wir haben eine Amtsnummer,
es ist die 0 2 2 1
2 5 4
6 3 0.
Also.
Fax.
Okay, Chat, Moment, was?
Hallo, ich habe mal eine dumme
frage mit aktuell im der fox bereich und nebenbei noch im studium eingeschrieben
nebenbei aber brauche noch viel zu lange glaubst du es lohnt sich den bachelor
fertig zu machen lieber auf der fox gilt fokus im prüfen hast du erfahrung
worauf firmen da ja
das kann ich jetzt so weit das weiß ich jetzt nicht was was du willst ich meine
es ist ja immer eine individuelle sache
was allerdings auch auf jeden Fall so ist,
im Durchschnitt wohlgemerkt, ja,
im Durchschnitt verdienst du nach einem Studium
mehr als ohne, im Durchschnitt.
Ja, das heißt nicht,
dass das jetzt auf dich individuell zutrifft.
Ich habe übrigens, by the way, auch nicht studiert, ja.
Im Durchschnitt.
Ich habe keine Ahnung,
wenn du jetzt einfach aufhörst, ist natürlich
verschwendete Zeit gewesen, dass du es überhaupt
gemacht hast. Also je nachdem,
wie lang das noch
dauert, vielleicht ist es schon sinnig,
das fertig zu machen.
Du kannst ja auch neben dem
Studium deine DevOps-Skills
improven.
Kann ich dir
nichts Gescheites zu raten.
Chat, was meint ihr?
Wisst doch immer Bescheid.
Ja, arbeiten kann man danach noch genug.
Das stimmt wohl auch, ja.
Ja, und irgendeinen Abschluss in irgendeiner Form ist auf jeden Fall sinnvoll.
Der Chat sagt, du solltest fertig studieren.
Ja, also
einen Abschluss in irgendeiner Art und Weise
brauchst du auf jeden Fall.
Ey, kann ich dazu nicht sagen.
Achso, du hast schon eine Ausbildung.
Ja, dann.
Ja, mehr kann ich zu nicht sagen.
Weiß nicht.
Oh, weiter.
Wer uns ein Fax schicken will, per Frage,
wir werden auch diese Faxe hier versuchen,
im Studio zu beantworten.
Jetzt geht es aber erstmal los mit Wolfgang Rudolf
und Daniel Rasch.
Ich möchte mal gerne wissen...
Du bleibst ja vielleicht auch nicht für immer da
und vielleicht hast du ja dann trotzdem noch mehr Möglichkeiten
bei deinem jetzigen Arbeitgeber.
Weißt ja nicht, wie sehr die da drauf gucken.
Das hängt immer ein bisschen von ab.
Aber schadet auf jeden Fall nichts,
es zu haben.
Wie komme ich ins Internet?
Ja, genau.
Der ist es.
Der macht noch auf YouTube heute ab und zu Videos.
Den meine ich.
Ja, der linke.
Jetzt kriegen wir gezeigt,
wie wir ins Internet kommen, 1999.
Sehr, sehr einfach geworden.
Vor Jahren hatte man schon Probleme.
Was Sie brauchen, ist zu Hause einen Telefonanschluss.
Nicht mal ein Telefon.
Das heißt, eine solche Dose.
Und die sollte, wenn sie gleichzeitig auch noch telefonieren wollen, das Telefon angeschlossen haben wollen, mindestens zwei in der Regel, aber drei dieser Anschlüsse haben.
Es war, das wissen die Leute heutzutage gar nicht mehr, deswegen muss ich jetzt Opa Max erzählt vom Krieg.
Früher hatten diese TAE-Dosen drei Anschlüsse und du konntest nicht jedes Gerät in jedes Ding stöpseln.
Die hatten unterschiedliche Stecker oder unterschiedliche Pins oder so, ich weiß nicht mehr.
du hattest, ich weiß gar nicht mehr wie das war
es gab irgendwie so Nebenstellen-Dinger
und ich, nicht dass ich jetzt
wirklich da durchblicken würde, großartig
ähm, zumindest war
das
komplizierter
als es aussieht, es war nicht einfach reinstecken
und es geht
also ich hab noch ne 3er TAE
Dose bei mir im Serverraum, aber die ist halt da
die ist nix mehr dran angeschlossen
Das Kabel habe ich zweckentfremdet.
deutsch für nicht fernsprecher also ich dachte es heißt nebenstelle ich dachte
es hat ich wusste gar nicht dass es nicht fernsprecher heißt
mindestens einmal f und einmal ein anschluss haben dann können sie daran
ein modem anschließen und jetzt wollte ich mal zeigen wie das eigentlich früher
aus da ging sowas mit akustik noch gar nicht so lustig an diese teilchen aus
da hast du telefonhörer reingeklemmt das ist das ist nochmals also das war noch
vor meiner Zeit Akustikkoppler.
oder 9,6k
Modems.
Ich mach schon noch
YouTube-Videos. Ich werd nie
aufhören mit YouTube-Videos. Nie ganz.
Oder sowas.
Oder ein ganz
altes Modem. Akustikkoppler.
Wartet mal.
Ja, so sah das damals aus.
Das ist ein Telefonhörer da drauf gestöpselt. Ihr kennt das vielleicht indirekt noch. So was hat ja ein Modem mittlerweile eingebaut. Wenn ihr damals den Telefonhörer abgehoben habt, während ihr mit dem Modem im Internet wart, da habt ihr diese Töne auch am Telefonhörer gehört.
früher musstest du das halt noch von hand machen muss zusammen drauf klipsen
ja oder du hast ein fax genau
akustik hoppler
oder ein preiswertes modem so wie es hier ist oder solche geräte wie sie hier stehen so wie
wir sie heute haben so ungefähr guck mal da ein elsa micro link office das hatte ich auch
Das war ein richtig nices, beste Modem überhaupt war das.
Das war nicht nur Modem, das war auch Fax- und Anrufbeantworter in einem.
Und es hatte 4 MB Flash, das heißt du konntest darauf Anrufe speichern und Faxe speichern, ohne dass der Rechner an sein musste.
Ne, Akustikoppler habe ich nie selbst benutzt.
Das war richtig das Beste.
Elsa Big Cooling Office.
Aber wenn man unterwegs ist, ist es viel schöner, wenn man so eine PCM-CAE-Karte oder neudeutsch PC-Karte hat.
Ja, das ist erstmal die Hardware, die drumherum ist. Und jetzt muss man noch einen Rechner haben, einen Computer.
Und da kann man entweder ein solches Notebook hier nehmen.
Ob der auch rebootet?
Aber es geht natürlich auch mit einem Rechner von zu Hause. Und da steht so ein Rechner.
Und jetzt das Besondere, was die meisten Leute gar nicht glauben, man muss nicht den neuesten Rechner haben,
sondern man braucht eigentlich nur einen Rechner, einen 486er, also einen ziemlich alten Rechner.
Und diesen Rechner, den man dann...
Also ich glaube 1999 hatte ich, ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher,
Was ich dafür, ich glaube, damals hatte ich ein Pentium 2 400 mit einer TNT 1 Grafikkarte.
Kommt das so ungefähr hin?
Wann kam die denn raus?
Okay, März 1998.
Wann kam der Pentium 2 raus?
Gibt es da irgendwie ein Jahr oder so?
Ja die waren in so komischen Cartridges als erstes und einziges
ja in dem Dreh
in dem Dreh
dann werde ich
das wahrscheinlich noch
so danach hatte ich einen
Adlon XP glaube ich
Adlon XP
wann kamen die Dinger dann raus
Release
2001. Okay, dann hatte ich auf jeden Fall dort noch den Pentium 2 400 und die TNT 1 Karte.
Ich habe damals den Rechner übertaktet von 400 auf 450.
Damals konntest du die CPUs noch nicht einzeln übertakten.
Damals konntest du nur mit FSB Frontside-Bass übertakten.
Und da habe ich meinen Frontside-Bass irgendwie ein bisschen hochgestellt von 100 auf,
ich weiß nicht, auf was man den hochstellen musste, dass der dann auf 450 läuft.
Und ich habe mich damals wieder Ultra-Hackerman gefühlt,
weil ich ins BIOS gegangen bin und dort eine Sache umgestellt habe und wieder raus bin.
Ich hatte auch Angst, dass mein Rechner danach abfackelt und sowas.
Da habe ich mich richtig gefeiert dafür.
Also in meiner Ansicht damals war das quasi Free-Leistung durch bisschen BIOS-Geklicke.
geklickt hat man damals im BIOS
und ich ein bisschen BIOS getippe.
Also ich war da 15.
Müsste ich gewesen sein.
1984 geboren.
War ich 15.
Ja.
Aber da habe ich mich geil gefühlt.
FSB übertakten.
Der reicht vollkommen aus für das Internet.
Ist das auch deine Meinung?
Ja, das ist mein Rechner. Man sieht da oben, dass das Kettenlaufwerk noch ein bisschen kaputt ist.
Ein 4,6, ein 8er war schon hardcore lahm.
Ich habe einen kleinen Browser da drauf.
Browser.
Jetzt bist du schon so weit gegangen.
Daniel, als erstes, wenn wir jetzt die Sachen hier haben, die müssen wir jetzt anschließen.
Die müssen wir zusammenschließen.
Wir haben am Modem eine serielle Schnittstelle.
Die schließe ich daran an.
Ich muss darauf achten, muss ich reden.
Chat, was mich damals auch immer verwirrt hat, ist...
Erinnerst du dich noch jemanden, Null-Modem-Kabel?
Ihr kennt bestimmt noch
Okay, es sagt keiner mehr was
Heutzutage
Null Modem Kabel konnte man damals
Mehrere Rechner, also, naja, mehrere
Drei, also eigentlich hast du zwei
Ne, ne, die muss man nicht terminieren
Da hatte ich Rechner
Mit einem Kollegen verbunden
Per Null Modem Kabel
Und
Die Parallelport
Null Modem Kabel
die waren etwas schneller.
Genau, das ist ein serielles Nullmodem-Kabel
und dann gab es auch parallele Nullmodem-Kabel.
Und die über einen Parallelport,
die waren etwas schneller.
Moment, man findet heute bei Ebay noch,
genau die Dinger, ja, die waren etwas schneller.
Und ich habe damals versucht, bei mir im Ort ein paralleles Nullmodem-Kabel zu kaufen.
Und es war damals wie heute, alle Elektronikläden sind absolut unfähige Kack-Noobs.
Elektronikläden damals waren halt 99,9% Autovideo, die von Computerkram absolut null Ahnung hatten
Da wollte ich ein Nullmodemkabel kaufen, ich dachte mir, das kann doch nicht so ein paralleles Nullmodemkabel
Ich dachte mir, das kann doch nicht so schwer sein
War es aber
Das ist ja auch da, wo die Drucker dran kommen
Nur das Druckerkabel auf der anderen Seite diesen komischen Druckeranschluss hatten.
Auf der einen Seite so und auf der anderen Seite, ähm, sag mal, Winter Cable Parallel.
Kable, Kable vor allem, ja.
Ja, so, so.
So sahen die, auf der einen Seite sahen die Druckerkabel so aus und auf der anderen nicht USB.
Auf der anderen Seite halt so, genau.
So sahen damals Druckerkabel aus.
Parallele Schnittstelle an Rechner.
Und das Ding kam an Drucker.
Ich weiß ehrlich gesagt bis heute nicht, warum das nicht einfach ein paralleler Anschluss auf beiden Seiten war mit diesen Steckern.
Warum das Druckerkabel auf der Druckerseite so ein hässliches, komisches Ding hatte.
kein schimmer
so weiter geht's
da ausschalten ja richtig ich habe jetzt hier dass das notebook das ist jetzt mal an in der
regel muss es eigentlich aus sein dann nimmt man hier wirklich dieses serielle kabel verbindet das
Hast du eventuell früher mal YouTube auf dem Kanal gemacht, der FPS-Max?
Was? Wie kommst du da drauf?
Ich kenne keinen FPS-Max.
Doch, doch, du hast recht.
Ich bin das.
Und ich mache auch ab und zu noch YouTube-Videos,
auch wenn das letzte schon über ein Jahr her ist.
Aber mal gucken, wie es zu Battlefield 6 aussieht.
Das ist ja hier ein Anschluss an den PC.
Das sieht man, da ist so wie die Maus, zumindest bei älteren Rechnern, das ist so ein kleiner, ich kann es hier mal zeigen.
Stimmt, damals hat man die Maus teilweise auch noch per seriellem Kabel angeschlossen, aber PS2-Mausbeste.
Genau, bei diesem D9-Stecker und bei älteren hat man einen großen, den DB25-Stecker, aber meistens ist beim Modem so ein Adapter dabei, dass man auf beide drauf kann.
Genau, das passt eigentlich in der Regel, genau.
Dann hier noch das schwarze Kabel, ist passend für den Telefonanschluss, das geht dann nachher in die TAE-Dose, wie Wolfgang es eben gesagt hat.
In den N-Stecker geht das Modem, nicht in den F-Stecker.
Das passt.
Genau.
So, und da muss man noch was dazu sagen.
Da gibt es merkwürdigerweise zwei verschiedene Normen.
Also nicht jedes Kabel passt dazu.
Man muss sich am besten eine Markierung drauf machen,
ob es vom Modem war oder von anderen Geräten.
Genau, man sollte es nachher nicht irgendwie vertauschen mit anderen Geräten.
Gut, jetzt habe ich die Hardware.
Was muss ich denn jetzt haben, wenn ich die angeschlossen habe an Software?
Jetzt braucht man Netscape.
Oder was hat man damals für einen Browser verwendet? Wahrscheinlich Mozilla, nee nicht Mozilla, Netscape, von Netscape Navigator hieß das Ding, Netscape Navigator.
Navigator.
Damit ich das alles miteinander
verbinden kann. Ja, Modem wird
eingeschaltet und danach den Rechner
hochfahren. Die neuen Modems werden
in der Regel eigentlich alle direkt erkannt.
Dann wird sofort gesagt, hier, Modem XY
ist gefunden, bitte legen Sie die CD
ein. Das macht man dann auch,
dann werden die Treiber installiert.
Da gab es dann die
berühmt-berüchtigte AOL-CD
mit 50 Gratistunden oder sowas.
... Software, die da für
Faxempfang, Anrufbeantworter etc.
Gebraucht okay, ich muss ich jetzt muss ich ja will ich ja in ein netzwerk in das internet hinein also muss in meinen rechner auch
Netzwerk fähig sein was mache ich dann ja jetzt habe ich hier erstmal vorbereitet wir gehen in die systemsteuerung
und da auf software
Ist ein bisschen größer müsste es schon zeigen leute
So geil war die auflösung damals noch nicht
Das ist ganz wichtig und dann moment was
Mit Ach und Krach erkenne ich, dass da Eigenschaften von Software steht.
Aber wirklich mit Ach und Krach nur, ja.
Das waren aber noch Zeiten, als die Windows-Systemsteuerung einheitlich aussah.
Gibt es hier unten unter Verbindungen, das ist ganz naheliegend.
Hier unten sieht man auch ein kleines Telefonsymbol.
DFÜ, genau.
Und da muss hier oben der oberste Eintrag DFÜ-Netzwerk.
Datenfernübertragung, Leute.
DFÜ-Netzwerk, wusste mein Häkchen.
Da kann ich mich noch dran erinnern, genau.
Und wenn du ins Internet wolltest,
ein Modem alleine hat ja nicht gereicht.
Du hast ja noch einen Provider gebraucht.
Irgendeinen Call-by-Call-Provider oder sowas.
Man darf nicht vergessen,
damals musstest du doppelt bezahlen.
Du musstest Telefongebühren bezahlen
für die Telefonverbindung von dir zu deinem Internetprovider.
und dann hat der Internetprovider noch datenmäßig abgerechnet.
Also du suchst dir beispielsweise von Microsoft oder irgendwie,
da gab es ja jede Menge Call-by-Call-Provider,
da hast du angerufen und die haben das abgerechnet
und die Telekom, über die du dich dahin verbunden hast,
hat auch nochmal abgerechnet.
Das war gar nicht so billig damals, sich mit dem Modem einzuloggen.
Richtig cool war es mit DSL.
Es gab nämlich mal eine Zeit,
dass man
am Sonntag
kostenlos mit DSL
surfen konnte.
Also,
ich glaube, da musste man nur Telefongebühren
bezahlen,
keine
Provider-Gedönsgebühren.
Und ich glaube,
mit einem speziellen Tarif war nicht mal Telefongebühren.
Sonntags war quasi kostenlos
und da konnte man sonntags richtig mit Kanalbündelung
Napster leer saugen
War das nicht so, dass man entweder telefonieren
oder im Internet surfen konnte? Das war so
Das war so
Bei DSL gab es keine Telefongebühren mehr
Du konntest nur eine Sache gleichzeitig machen
Deswegen war ja damals ISDN auch ganz cool
weil da hattest du zwei Leitungen
Konntest du mit einer Leitung surfen
mit anderen Leitungen auch telefonieren.
Heute ist das alles obsolet, weil eh alles
IP ist.
Ja, das ist lange her.
Ich habe mehrere
solche Videos gemacht, aber
und hast du dich, für was hast du dich
entschieden? Bist du Fisi oder bist
du FIAE?
Jetzt geworden.
Oder was ganz was anderes?
Zuschauer. Du bist Fachinformator
Anwendungsentwicklung geworden. Nice.
Die Zuschauer. Danke.
Okay. Moment, das war eine
nicht nur Live-Übertragung,
das war auch mit Live-Publikum damals.
Hi, Max Chainlaw hier.
Ernsthaft? Das glaube ich dir
nicht. Wirklich?
Chainlaw, du musst beweisen, dass du's bist.
Sass.
Aber falls du es bist,
schön, dass du wieder da bist.
Aber ich glaube es dir trotzdem nicht.
Ich glaub's dir immer noch nicht.
Vielleicht glaub ich dir jetzt schon ein bisschen.
Warum heißt du nicht mehr Chainlord?
Chainlord?
Account gebannt.
Okay, dann glaube ich dir doch, dass du es bist.
Leute, der ist wirklich gebannt, der Account.
Dann glaube ich dir.
Ich habe jetzt ein paar Mal in den letzten Streams schon gesagt, wo ist eigentlich der
Chainlore?
Ja, da ist er.
Da ist er.
Hat mich schon gefragt, wo du steckst.
Was hast du angestellt, dass du gebannt wurdest?
Wobei, erzähl es besser nicht.
Vielleicht ist das Toss.
Ich will es gar nicht wissen.
Okay, lass mal weiter gucken.
Die Zuschauer, ich glaube, sie haben genau hingehört.
Jetzt denken alle Zuschauer, hoffentlich fragt er mich nicht.
Ganz seltsam, das können wir hier mal zeigen. Die junge Dame ist im Internet, sagt sie,
mir hat aber keine Ahnung davon, möchte auch gar nichts dazu sagen.
Da sitzen hier zwei junge Männer, man kann es gar nicht glauben, die sind nicht im Internet.
Was?
Nicht.
Das ist einfach zu teuer und der Zeitaufwand ist einfach zu umständlich, denke ich.
Wie jetzt?
Ja, weiß man dann, was es kostet?
Ungefähr so muss ich damals auch ausgeschaut haben.
Der ist bestimmt auch so um die 15, hä?
Ne, der Typ ist heute so alt wie ich.
Wenn der 15 ist, dann ist der heute 41, wie ich...
Der ist 20, okay.
Ja gut, dann habe ich vielleicht ein bisschen...
Der ist nicht 15, okay.
Chat, dann nicht.
Ja, die regulären Telefongebühren eben.
Ja, das stimmt.
Das lässt sich als Schüler nicht so gut finanzieren.
Als Schüler? Leute, der ist keine 20.
Der ist Schüler. Also der ist 15.
Der war damals ungefähr so alt, wie ich damals auch war.
Ist er meinetwegen 18.
Wisst ihr eine Sache, die ich echt blöd finde, dass ich das nie gemacht habe damals?
Und das ist auf die Cebit fahren.
Die gibt es ja nicht mehr mittlerweile.
Ich wäre damals echt gerne auf die CeBIT gefahren, aber ich hatte keinen, der mitkommt.
CeBIT hat sich auch irgendwie selbst abgeschafft. Gibt es ja schon seit einer Weile nicht mehr.
Dann müsste der Vater ja sagen.
Der sagt nicht ja, oder?
Der ist nicht unbedingt gewillt dazu, ne.
Also man hört ja manchmal auch super Zahlen, dass es um 300, 400 Mark monatlich rauskommt.
Ja klar, damals konntest du nicht 24...
Die guckt ein bisschen Kappa-mäßig, oder?
Findet ihr nicht auch?
Die hat voll dieses Kappa-Smile.
Hat so eine gewisse Ähnlichkeit, oder?
Muss aber nicht sein. Man kann es auch vernünftig machen.
Ich habe auch nicht so großes Interesse daran, deswegen...
Gibt es denn in der Schule, ich höre eben Schüler, gibt es denn da Leute, die im Internet sind?
Ja, die Schule ist auch im Internet bei uns.
Guck mal, damals waren die Schulen schon im Internet.
Man hat da recherchiert und so weiter, wenn man das...
Ja, man hat teilweise die Möglichkeit, da reinzugehen und insofern ist das ganz okay.
Jetzt sitzt hier jemand, der ist bei der Bundeswehr und sagt, ich bin nicht im Internet, weil ich keine Zeit habe.
Ja, das ist richtig. Dienstlich bin ich die ganze Woche in meinem Standort.
In der Kaserne gibt es kein Internet.
Nur am Wochenende nach Hause und die Zeit am Wochenende ist eben auch knapp.
Und da will ich halt nicht auch noch...
Und was kommt nach der Bundeswehr?
Nach der Bundeswehr kommt das Studium. Ich hoffe, dass ich es dann da schaffe, endlich mal ins Internet reinzukommen.
Ist denn das Wissen über das Internet schon da, dass man da leicht reinkommt?
Weiß man denn schon, wenn man nicht im Internet ist, was man braucht dazu?
Ja, doch. Ich denke mal, da kann ich mich auch auf Freunde berufen, die halt die Ahnung haben,
die können mir da Auskunft geben, wie ich das am einfachsten und am billigsten vielleicht auch mache.
und ich denke mir, das wird sich irgendwie geben mit der Zeit hin.
Wie sieht es denn eigentlich zu Hause aus?
Wenn ihr in der Kaserne damals Internet gehabt hättet, hätten sie alle vom Rechner gehangen.
Was ist mit dem Telefon? Ist das analog oder ist das ISDN?
ISDN.
ISDN?
Ja, ja. Wir haben noch analog.
Noch? Ja, hättet ihr mal gewusst, das analoge Telefon überlebt ISDN um einige Jahrzehnte.
Hätte man damals auch nicht gedacht.
Wurde nach zwei Monaten bei der Deutschen Bank auch gekickt.
Was machst du denn, Chainlore?
The fuck?
Bin jetzt fiesi bei einer Gemeinde, bin Turnschuh-Admin wie ich.
Ja, wie ich früher.
Was treibst du denn?
Du machst doch einen ganz kompetenten, normalen Eindruck.
Bisschen rumgetrolle und ASCII-Dings gespamme.
Was treibst du denn?
Wegen der Übernahme.
Haben alle Azubis gekickt? Aha.
In der Probezeit.
Das ist aber assi.
Und was machen die jetzt?
Jetzt haben sie keinen Nachwuchs mehr.
Ist auch sehr kurzsichtig, oder?
Aber gut, dass du was Neues gefunden hast.
Das gucken wir mal weiter.
Ich bin schon nicht so begeistert an ISDN-Anschluss.
Und wenn der Internetanschluss kommt, dann muss auch ISDN herbei, oder?
Ich denke mal, ja.
Ja, diese Frage, ich denke mal, ja, das sollten wir jetzt mal ganz kurz erörtern.
Man kann ja...
Ja, damals haben viele gedacht, ISDN ist die Zukunft.
Aber hätte man damals, damals hätte man nicht gedacht, dass analoge Telefone und analoge Telefonanschlüsse ISDN überleben werden.
Im analogen Netz, also in dem alten Telefonnetz, ISDN machen, das Internet machen, das geht wunderbar mit den schnellen Modems.
Und man kann natürlich auch noch schneller eventuell das Ganze mit ISDN betreiben, Wolfgang.
Ja, man kann mit Kanalbündelung das Doppelte bezahlen auch.
Wir haben eben das analoge Netz besprochen und da werden ja Informationen mit Tönen übertragen.
Unterschiedliche Töne repräsentieren unterschiedliche Bits, also ein Bit-Gesetz oder nicht.
Während im digitalen Netz, da haben wir keine Töne mehr, die übertragen werden,
sondern da haben wir gleich Bits, so wie sie im Computer sind,
allerdings in einer anderen Reihenfolge, in einer anderen Struktur, mit einem anderen Protokoll.
Michael, wenn wir rausgehen.
ISDN war super kompliziert.
Wir hatten das in der Berufsschule ein bisschen, das war aber auch schon ausgehend,
damals, also auslaufend
damals.
Also ISDN war super komplizierter Kram.
Wahrscheinlich hat
deswegen auch der oldschool-analoge
Telefonanschluss ISDN überlebt.
Jetzt wollen wir einfach mal
zeigen, wir haben drüben gesehen ein Modem,
das ist das, was wir brauchen. Hier brauchen wir
keinen Modem, sondern hier nehmen wir zum Beispiel
eine solche Karte.
Wie heißt diese Karte?
ISDN-Karte.
Hier ist eine Karte von 3.0.
Grundsätzlicher Unterschied, es gibt
Passive und Aktive. Die Aktiven,
die arbeiten selbst. Da ist also so eine Art
Ablaufsteuerung-Prozessor drauf. Bei den Passiven
muss der Rechner das machen. Richtig, ganz genau.
Jetzt habe ich hier eine gesehen, die hast du da mitgebracht.
Es ist jetzt ja nicht so,
als, naja gut,
aus der heutigen Zeit ist natürlich das lachhaft
so, die zusätzliche Rechenleistung
in den Rechner aufbringen musste. Aber wenn du mit einem
486 ja ins Internet gegangen bist, sah das schon
wieder anders aus.
Hier, guck mal, das sind doch eindeutig
Fritz, Fritz-Produkte, die hier rumstehen
mit dem blauen und dem gelben und dem roten Text
drauf.
Als Vergleich dazu legen, ist das jetzt eine Karte für arme
Leute, weil das so wenig drauf ist? Ja, das ist also
der Original Siemens-Chipsatz, unter
der Bezeichnung läuft das Ganze. Das ist also die einfachste
Art der ESDN-Karte. So hoch integriert
ist das mittlerweile. Man hat zwei Chips drauf und
ein paar Dioden und damit ist die Sache schon erledigt.
Ganz genau. Bei komplexeren Karten sind halt noch
weitere Funktionen drin. Man kann noch ein externes
Telefon anschließen. Man kann
andere Features noch nutzen.
Das ist also jetzt Stand der Technik,
Das kann aber auch bedeuten, dass die Dinge jetzt noch billiger werden.
So ab 100 Mark gibt es sie ja schon.
Gibt es sie schon, richtig.
In der Preisklasse haben wir von 100 Mark bis natürlich über 2000 Mark.
Das sind dann wirklich professionelle Karten für Server.
Aber ich sage mal, 100 Mark ist völlig ausreichend.
So etwas sollte nicht mehr als 10 Mark kosten, denke ich mal.
Das hier sind jetzt das Gegenstück zum Modem.
Und zwar nennt man das hier Terminal Adapter.
Das wird also auch an die serielle Schnittstelle angeschlossen des Rechners und die andere Seite an das digitale Netz.
Richtig, ganz genau.
Da muss man aber jetzt gar nicht mehr so viel ändern, denn die Daten kommen ja schon digital da rein und gehen digital raus.
Haben die weniger zu tun als ein analoges Modem?
Ja, natürlich, sicher. Von der Technik her eigentlich ist es weniger.
Merkwürdigerweise sind diese Geräte immer noch etwas teurer als Modems.
Das Leben ist voller Merkwürdigkeit.
Jetzt wollen wir aber mal zeigen, wo kommt das eigentlich ran.
100 Mark, ja.
Ich habe also an einem solchen Terminaladapter oder an einer solchen Karte hier hinten einen sogenannten Westernstecker.
Da wird das reingestopft. So, da ist dann ein Telefon drauf. So, einmal da.
Die andere Seite kommt jetzt an ein Gerät, das bekomme ich von der Telekom an die Wand genagelt.
Ein NTBA ist das.
So, da muss man aber dazu sagen, so, jetzt angeschlossen und fertig.
Jetzt muss man dazu sagen, wenn man sich das von der Telekom an die Wand nageln oder schrauben lässt, dann kostet das Ganze 200 Mark.
Und wenn man das selber macht, weil wie man hier sieht, ist hier also auch ein Steckeradapter dran, dass man das direkt in seine Telefonlose stecken kann.
Also das hatte ich nie, dass die Telekom mir das an die Wand schraubt. Das ist kein Splitter, das ist ein NTBA, das ist für die ISDN-Sachen. Der Splitter ist davor, falls es ein DSL-Anschluss ist. Damals gab es ja noch bei denen zumindest kein DSL.
Ein selber installiert kostet nur 100 Mark.
Das lohnt sich.
Also für 100 Mark einen Stecker in die Dose stecken ist kein Problem.
Drüben haben wir gesehen, für Notebooks gab es da eine spezielle Lösung.
Richtig.
Da hast du was in der Hand.
Auch hier haben wir eine ISDN-Lösung für Notebooks.
Funktioniert im Prinzip wie die Lösung für die Modems.
Ansonsten volle ISDN-Funktionalität.
Das heißt, ich kann also auch beide ISDN-B-Kanäle nutzen, trotzdem die Karte so klein ist.
Das heißt also, das ist die ganze Technik, dass die ganze Technik um ISDN-Nutzung zu kommen.
Jetzt hast du schon wieder was gesagt.
Da müssen wir nochmal diesen NTBA zeigen.
Da habe ich jetzt einen Stecker reingesteckt und hier daneben ist noch ein Anschluss.
Kann man hier zwei Geräte anschließen?
Richtig, zwei. Man kann aber auch sich so einen Verteiler kaufen.
Ich glaube, ISDN ging bis zu acht.
Abnehmen. Ich wiege aktuell um die 80 Kilo plus minus.
Warum ich nicht so viel gemacht habe, habe ich in einem der letzten Streams schon mal erzählt.
will ich jetzt eigentlich gar nicht so viel drüber
mich auslassen
wenn du rewatchst dann hast du viel zu rewatchen
vielleicht gibt es mal Wubblos TV die Sachen schon und du kannst mit der
Volltextsuche das finden
genau Wubblos TV da kannst du Volltextsuche machen
Dann such mal nach krank oder so.
So kleine Kästchen.
Da kann man bis zu 6, 7, 8 oder 10 Geräte anschließen.
Also 8 dürfen wir ja anschließen.
Richtig.
Wir können aber nur 2 gleichzeitig nutzen.
Man kann nur 2 gleichzeitig nutzen.
Weil eine ISDN-Ladung 2 B-Kanäle hat und dann heißt das für uns so wie 2 analoge Ladungen.
Richtig.
Gut, jetzt haben wir da noch so ein schwarzes Gerät.
Ja, das ist was ganz Besonderes.
Und zwar ist das ein ISDN-Endgerät für USB.
für die USB.
Es gab damals
schon USB.
Das war aber dann ganz
neuer Shit.
1999.
Das war super aktuell.
So sahen damals übrigens auch eine ganze Weile
noch die Stecker auf Geräteseite
aus vom USB.
Diese eckigen Dinger.
Mein Audio-Interface hat auch noch so einen Stecker.
Genau das gleiche wie bei den analogen Endgeräten, also bei den Modems.
Man installiert ein virtuelles Modem und geht dann damit online.
Das heißt also, wenn ich digital arbeiten will, dann muss ich die gleiche Software im Rechner haben,
brauche aber noch eine Zusatzsoftware, die nach außen so tut, als hätte ich im Rechner jetzt ein Modem eingebaut.
Dann kann man auch alles nutzen, faxen, alles was möglich ist.
Ist soweit ganz einfach. Mal sehen, gehen wir mal wieder zum Aufgang.
Faxen scheint da voll angesagt noch gewesen zu sein damals.
Die erwähnen Fax bestimmt schon zum achten Mal.
Warum hat das so lange bestanden?
Ja, weil das die Art war, Geräte anzuschließen, bevor es USB-C gab.
Also, das war ganz normal.
Geräte hatten so einen Stecker.
So kleine Geräte hatten Micro-USB, aber die meisten anderen größeren Geräte hatten
diesen eckigen.
So ein bisschen klar geworden ist.
Ja, ich habe mich in der Zwischenzeit so ein bisschen unterhalten hier mit den jungen Männern über ISDN und Analogtechnik.
Okay, die sind eher 15, oder?
Alle drei sind im Internet drin. Wie oft bist du drin im Internet?
Am Tag?
Eineinhalb Stunden so.
Und über ISDN, oder?
Ja, ISDN.
Also in dem Alter war ich damals so.
Ist das ein schicker ISDN zu Hause zu haben, also ein analoges Netz?
Ich denke mal, das ist billiger.
Nein, das ist nicht billiger.
Was sagt denn der Vater zu den Kosten, die da entstehen?
Der Vater freut sich vor allem, dass er noch telefonieren kann,
während der damals Counter-Strike oder andere Half-Life-Mods im Internet gespielt hat.
Hattest du auch so eine Frisur?
Weiß ich gar nicht mehr.
Ich hatte mal lange Heavy-Metal-Haare. Kann ich mir heute gar nicht mehr vorstellen. Aber das war, glaube ich, danach.
Also es hält sich noch in Grenzen.
Will Sins, weißt du das überhaupt?
Ne, das weiß ich nicht.
Wie sieht es denn hier aus? Auch ISDN oder analog?
Analog.
Analog. Wie sieht es denn da aus? Wie oft?
Naja, mindestens zwei Stunden.
Leute, stellt euch vor, die Leute aus diesem Beitrag, die sind heute 40.
Die Telefonrechnung lässt einen grüßen.
Wie hoch ist die? Weißt du auch nichts davon, ne?
Also 100 Mark mindestens noch drauf.
Nur fürs Internet?
Ja, mindestens.
Und was sagt der Vater dazu?
Nicht begeistert.
Und dann haben wir jemanden, der hat einen super Anschluss, ne?
Ja, ich habe diesen 60-Stunden-Pauschaltarif von NetCologne.
da kann für 74 mark im monat 60 stunden surfen ohne telefon erreicht das denn oder wird das
auch noch überschritten die 60 stunden jetzt ich habe jetzt erst seit mitte januar und da
war ich letzten monat 62 stunden die zwei die kann man glaube auch diese kosten ja auch nicht
also viel dann die zweite also noch drei marken drei mark die stunde alter das war teuer und was
machst du da alles? Drei Mark die Stunde! Das ist schon ordentlich.
Im Internet? Alles mögliche. Hausaufgaben, Hilfen. Ich habe eine eigene Homepage, ich chatte viel.
ICQ hat man damals benutzt.
Ich hört mir immer, dass die deutschen Schulen, dass die so ein bisschen nachlässig behandelt
werden was so internet angeht aber ich höre dass in allen schulen woher kommt überall ich weiß heute
noch meine icq nummer internet ist und wie sieht es denn da aus mit der bisschen langsam habe ich
gehört bisschen langsam ist das internet oder der schule es geht geht aber hier ist doch das
eine erste in leitung wie viele leute müssen sich die teilen 10 rechner und da kommt schon
mal zu staunen oder also ist man dann schon besser dran wenn man zu hause eine eigene ist
der in leitung hat und dann auch 60 stunden daran kann für 70 mark im monat ja also das
ist n ist nicht mehr unbekannt wir wissen ja sind schon mittlerweile über zehn millionen
glaube ich in der bundesrepublik neues gibt es auf der telekommunikationsszene von gerhard pasch
bis zum 2.2 erzielt uns jetzt von den spielekonsolen und 1 soll jede deutsche
schule einen internetanschluss haben das versprach bundeskanzler gerhard schröder
bis jetzt seien dank der initiative schulen ans netz rund ein viertel der 44.000 schulen online
schröder und da ist es dann stehen geblieben lernen will den computer zu nutzen zeichnet
internetanbieter arbeiten von schülern aus zusammen mit microsoft chef bill gates der
schwerreiche amerikaner verabredete bei seinem besuch in nordrhein westfalen internet explorer
bestimmt bestimmt activex steuergedöns elemente mit ministerpräsident clemens auch gleich eine
initiative zum internethandel in dortmund soll ein ausbildungs und dienstleistungszentrum für
e-commerce entstehen die premiere der neuen intel prozessoren pensium 3 wird begleitet
durch einen boykott aufruf us verbraucherschützer kritisieren dass mit der einprogrammierten
seriennummer jeder pension recht da das hat damals die leute nun alter wenn es
heute war vergleicht das hat damals die leute auf die barrikaden gebracht die
gleichen leute ist damals auf die barrikaden gebracht haben scheren heute
ihre keine ahnung urlaubsfotos auf instagram mit genauen locations und
posten alles in irgendwelche cloud ja das gab es damals ja ja da kann ich mich
auch noch daran erinnern da gab es so software und die konnte
quasi anhand der uhrzeit den billigsten call by call anbieter benutzen und so
was ja
...
Damals haben sie sich darüber aufgelegt,
dass die CPU eine Seriennummer
hat.
...in einem Computernetzwerk
identifizierbar werde. Intel versprach
lediglich das Abschalten des Codes,
nicht die Produktionsanstellung.
Wie willst du mit einer CPU-Seriennummer
in einem Netzwerk was identifizieren?
Ist jetzt nicht so, dass
irgendwo in einem Ethernet-Frame
oder in einem IP-Package die CPU-
Seriennummer drin steht.
Keine Slots mehr.
Postlos.
Frankfurt an, die Online-Nutzung auf dreiviertel pro Minute zu reduzieren.
Handys werden fit fürs Internet mit der neuen Funktechnik GPRS, die...
Ach nee, ach nee, aber gab's damals nicht noch WAP-Webseiten und sowas?
Wie findest du das Golem-Redesign hässlich?
Telekom setzt als erster Netzbetreiber den neuen GSM-Standard General Packet Radio Service,
kurz GPRS genannt, in ihrem T-Mobil-Netz ein.
Damit verzehnfacht sich bei Handys der Datendurchsatz auf 115 Kilobit pro Sekunde.
Guck mal, schneller als daheim im Modem warst du damals schon mobile.
Auch im Festnetz kommen bald breitbandige Netzanschlüsse.
T-Online-Chef Eric Danke kündigte TDSL an.
Eine Technik, die auf herkömmlichen Kupferleitungen Datenraten bis zu einem Megabit pro Sekunde zum Download bereitstellen will.
T-Online will den asymmetrischen Netzzugang zum Download...
Da hat man es doch gerade mal gesehen. Also was haben wir denn hier? Analoge Modems?
56k
als die 128
mit Kanalbündelung, wohlgemerkt.
SDSL,
was damals so gut wie keiner bekommen konnte.
Oder hier normales
DSL mit
Testphase.
Ich habe euch ja die Story von meinem ersten DSL-Anschluss schon
Da gibt es sogar ein eigenes Video zu
Zu meinem ersten DSL-Anschluss
Wie ich da monatelang aufs Modem geguckt habe
Jeden Tag
Ob es nicht doch so
Ich hätte wetten können
Ich hatte 99
Ende 99 hatte ich schon DSL.
Da ging es bei den Amis schon zur Sache.
Ich dachte, wir kriegen jetzt was über 128-Bit-Spiele-Konsolen erzählt, wie er das am Anfang geteasert hat.
Ja, das war richtig geil, einen der ersten DSL-Anschlüsse zu haben.
Da hat man sich wieder King gefühlt hier.
Hat bloß noch der Fanatic Headshot-Controller gefehlt.
Das einzige Problem bei DSL damals war, Fastpath gab es nicht.
da war das künstlich langsam. Ich mein immer noch besser als mit analog.
Es hätte viel besser sein können.
Ja da gibt es doch schon einiges und zwar zum einen es wurde eben bei ESDN
erwähnt da gibt es so was wie ein NTBA und das berichten hier zum Beispiel auch einige Wissen.
Max, glaubst du eigentlich, dass Android wirklich das Sideloaden von Apps ab nächstes Jahr verbieten wird?
Ja, glaube ich.
Was ich halt richtig dämlich finde, für mich ist das eines der größten Vorteile von Android,
dass das System noch in gewisser Weise ein bisschen offener ist als das komplett abgeschottete iOS.
Du kannst ja bei iOS auch theoretisch was sideloaden, aber das ist so umständlich
und verfällt auch irgendwie nach sieben Tagen wieder und sowas,
dass das keiner macht und dass sich das nicht lohnt.
Bei Android war das viel besser gelöst.
Ich glaube, dass sie das machen wollen. Ich fände es aber für die Plattform ziemlich schlecht, wenn es passiert.
Ich will nicht wissen, was das denn jetzt heißt, NTBA, Michael.
NTBA. Okay, ich habe absolut keine Ahnung, wie für NTBA steht. Ich weiß nur, was es ist.
Das ist diese Box, wo ISDN-Kabel reinkommen.
Netz? Irgendwas mit Netz bestimmt.
Teilnehmer? Netz? Teilnehmer?
Abschluss.
Basisabschluss.
Okay, ich habe keiner.
NTBA.
So schlecht war ich gar nicht.
So schlecht war ich doch gar nicht
mit meinem zusammengereimten, oder?
Netzabschluss von einem ISDN-Basisanschluss.
Jetzt mal ohne Scheiß.
Für das, dass ich null Plan davon hatte,
was NTBA heißt, war das doch relativ nah dran.
Ich wüsste es auch. Ich wüsste es, glaube ich.
Gut, Wolfgang, dann sag es.
Netzwerk-Terminal-Basis-Adapter. Basis-Anschluss. So ungefähr.
Basic Access, ja, richtig. Netzwerk-Abschluss für den Basis-Anschluss.
Also das ist diese Kiste, die man bekommt von der Telekom, wenn man sich auf ISDN ummeldet.
Kostenlos, ja.
Die es im Moment übrigens nicht gibt.
Wir haben schon wieder zurückgerudert. Ach, tatsächlich, ja.
Ich glaube, zwei Monate warten, bis die Dinger wieder kommen.
Wenn man sich jetzt für ein ES3 anmeldet, dauert es zwei Monate.
Zwei, drei Wochen.
Es ist eigentlich unglaublich, was da so alles passieren kann.
Was haben wir noch?
Da ist zum Beispiel auch die Frage aufgekommen, wir haben viele, die zwar schon ein Modem bei sich zu Hause stehen,
zum Beispiel 14-4er-Moden, und jetzt fragen sie sich, da ja so viel über 56k-Modems erzählt wird,
oder auch gelesen und geschrieben wird, ob es sich überhaupt lohnt, dann auf ein 56k-Modem umzusteigen,
oder ob sie halt dieses 14-4 immer noch benutzen können.
Ja, wer benutzt 14-4er Modems?
Ich nicht mehr. Ich benutze schon ISCL mittlerweile und bin auch sehr froh drüber.
Aber 56k muss es vielleicht nicht unbedingt sein, ist aber was den Modem angeht schon der Standard.
Und wenn man, was war das, Mark?
14-4er.
14-4er ist schon ein paar Jährchen alt, da würde ich schon empfehlen auf 56k umzusteigen.
Daniel, kann das sein, dass ich letztens das 56er für 99 Mark gesehen habe? Ich glaube ja, ne?
Das kann sein, ja. Aber da ist mal die Frage, was dabei ist. Ob da Kabel dabei sind, wie lang, wie kurz die sind, was für Software auch dabei ist natürlich.
Ja, wenn es aber auch schon 56k Modems gibt, lohnt sich das dann überhaupt noch auf ISDN umzusteigen?
Ja, das ist die Frage.
Tja, ich hätte damals alles an Bandbreite genommen, was irgendwie möglich war. Also ISDN-Beste bis DSL am Start war.
das war auch die Zeit damals,
wo man Napster verwendet hat.
Halb Napster
leer gesaugt hat mit Kanalbündelung.
Ja, also
man muss da ganz klar sagen,
ein 56k Modem macht nicht
56k Daten übertragen, sondern
was effektiv rauskommt, ist vielleicht ein bisschen
über 30. Und ISDN ist da immer noch
deutlich schneller. Also es lohnt sich schon
auf die Dauer. Und bei ISDN hat man
ja auch zwei Leitungen. Das heißt, wenn sie dann wirklich
das Netz belagern, da darf der Rest der Familien
immer noch telefonieren.
Zumindest einer.
Ja, habt ihr noch was da drüben?
Ja, hier ist noch eine Frage, die wurde glaube ich auch eben schon ein bisschen beantwortet.
Und zwar kam es hier die Frage auf, was ihr mit aktiven und passiven ESDN-Karten habt.
Woher weiß ich denn, ob ich jetzt eine aktive ESDN-Karte oder eine passive?
Wenn sie teuer ist, ist es eine aktive Karte.
Wenn sie billig ist, ist es eine passive Karte.
Das ist auch das Erste, was ich gesagt hätte.
Wahrscheinlich steht es auch drauf irgendwo.
Wenn jetzt der Preis vielleicht nicht so wichtig ist, aber wenn ich halt gerne, ich habe einen Rechner bei mir zu Hause stehen,
ja und jetzt möchte ich gerne ISDN machen, weiß aber jetzt nicht, welche ich dafür benutzen muss.
Also ich würde mal einfach dazu sagen, bei einer passiven ISDN, wenn eine passive ISDN-Karte reicht,
ist es grundsätzlich für den Hausgebrauch. Wo man eine aktive nehmen sollte, ist für den Einsatz in Unternehmen,
für den Einsatz in Servern zum Beispiel, wenn ich so Abteilungs-Server habe.
Und wo es vielleicht noch Sinn macht, wenn man ganz alte Rechner nimmt, die die Leistung nicht bringen,
eine passive Karte zu nutzen, also so ein 486er, wie wir ihn bereits hier drüben gesehen haben.
Dort würde ich also auch eine aktive Karte reinsetzen, wenn ich ihn unbedingt dort mit der Kiste ISDN machen würde.
Man muss glaube ich da noch dazu sagen, in Servern oder in Firmen ja nur deswegen,
weil dort mehrere aus dem Netzwerk dann über eine Karte in das Internet gehen können.
Nur da macht es Sinn, denn sonst wenn es einer machen würde, würde ja da auch nur eine aktive Karte rein.
Hört ihr auch im Hintergrund ab und zu diese Faxgeräusche?
Ja, ich möchte nur sagen, wir haben es gut im WDR. Wir sitzen an unserem Schreibtisch und haben dort Internet, denken gar nicht darüber nach, ob das was kostet, ob es nichts kostet. Wir haben da 4 Megabit, das geht alles wunderbar.
4 Megabit war ja damals absoluter Luxus, Alter.
Das sieht nicht so aus, wenn man zu Hause privat ist, sondern man muss ja irgendwie, wenn man auch die Technik vorhanden hat,
man muss ja irgendwo einen Provider, einen neudeutschen Vermittler finden. Wie geht das? Was kann man da empfehlen?
Genau, das ist das Problem, da haben wir bisher noch nicht darüber gesprochen.
Wir haben jetzt hardwaremäßig den Zugang festgestellt, aber wir müssen ja noch einen Diensteanbieter, einen Provider haben,
der uns jetzt den Zugang zum Internet bringt. Und da gibt es eine ganze Menge verschiedene,
Also ich glaube, in Deutschland haben wir so um die 30, 40 verschiedene Provider.
Es gab damals jede Menge.
Große, kleine, mittlere.
Jeder kennt noch diese komische AOL-CD.
AOL-CD, 50 Stunden gratis und danach hast du ein Zwangsabo an der Backe gehabt.
So Call-by-Call-Anbieter waren damals eigentlich noch am besten.
Ich glaube, das hast du am Ende dann auch bezahlt über die Telefonrechnung.
Grundsätzliche Unterschiede haben wir einmal.
Es gibt welche, die sind flächendeckend zum Ortstarif zu erreichen.
und es gibt welche, die sind eben nur in Ballungsräumen zum Ortstorif zu erreichen und von außen her mit einem Ferngespräch.
Ja, man sollte auch dazu sagen, dass es auch noch halt Provider oder Anbieter gibt, die noch einen sogenannten Mehrwert liefern.
Das heißt, die bieten weitere Informationen, die man so im Internet eigentlich nicht bekommt.
Was ist das für ein Mehrwert?
Mehrwert sind zum Beispiel, dass sie Nachrichten halt einkaufen von irgendwelchen großen Newsagenturen,
dass sie die exklusiv quasi auf der Webseite anzeigen, dass man Online-Banking machen kann,
gesichertes Online-Banking, das bietet auch noch lange nicht jeder Provider und jede Bank an.
Das sind so diese Mehrwerte, die dort...
Stimmt, bald ist Prime Day, gell? In zwei, drei Tagen.
Habe ich doch irgendwas bei Amazon gesehen.
Wie suche ich mir einen solchen Provider aus?
Es gibt so viele verschiedene. Worauf muss ich denn achten?
Sind die im Preis auch unterschiedlich?
Ja, die sind natürlich auch im Preis unterschiedlich.
Ich empfehle immer, wenn mich jemand fragt, einschlägige Zeitungen sich zu kaufen.
Man geht in den Kiosk, geht...
Man kann sich zum Beispiel eine CT kaufen.
Dort in die Computerabteilung, gucke einfach mal verschiedene Internet- oder Computerzeitschriften durch und da sind in der Regel immer bei fast allen, hier unten sieht man sie, CDs drin.
Das gehörte, das ist auch witzig, das gehörte damals zum guten Ton, dass eine Computerzeitschrift hatte immer eine CD dabei.
Du hattest quasi kaum eine Computerzeitschrift ohne CD.
Auch Gaming, auch die GameStar damals. GameStar hatte immer eine CD dabei mit irgendwelchen Demos und Patches und Raumschiff GameStar und so komischem Zeug drauf.
Ja, das hat mit der Zeit dann aber nachgelassen.
Ich meine, die meisten Leute haben im Rechner heutzutage gar kein optisches Laufwerk mehr.
Jetzt war Chat, Frage an euch, habt ihr noch ein optisches Laufwerk im Rechner, ja oder ne?
An CD-Laufwerk, DVD, Blu-Ray, also ich hab nix mehr, ich hab nix mehr.
Ich hab letztens erst wieder, weil ich drüben im Wohnzimmer DVD gucken wollte,
ähm, hab ich die PS4 rübergestellt und angeschlossen.
USB-CD-Laufwerk.
Das habe ich auch noch irgendwo rumfliegen.
Ein USB-DVD-Laufwerk.
Das ist ein Blu-ray-Brenner.
Ich habe noch ganz viele olle CDs hier rumliegen.
auf dem Schrank. Die habe ich beim Umzug
mitgenommen, habe ich einfach alles in eine Kiste
geschmissen. Die stehen hier immer noch. Da sind massig
CDs drin.
Normale CDs,
GameStar, Zeitschrift-
CDs und
Spiele,
Xbox-CDs, DVDs.
Umzug?
Ich rede von 2013, wo ich umgezogen
bin.
Hast du auch noch einen CD-Tower? Nee.
Nee.
Stimmt, stimmt.
Da war es richtig cool,
wenn du damals so ein Ding hast, was CDs gravieren konnte.
Genau.
Wer hat damals
als CD-Brenner
habe ich eine ganze Weile dieses...
Gibt es das eigentlich auch?
Nero Burning.
Hier, das.
Gibt es das?
Meist verkauftes Brennprogramm.
Okay, das gibt es immer noch.
gibt es wirklich leute die das heute noch kaufen 50 euro für ein programm was auch aussieht wie
von windows 2000 noch muss man ja mal ehrlich sagen 2023 daran ist wahrscheinlich nichts 2023
aber das kann mittlerweile auch usb sticks flaschen ja gut weil man sonst nichts mehr
brauche
Das das hatte ich früher immer und danach
danach habe ich festgestellt eigentlich braucht man gar keine paid software sondern gab es noch irgendwie cd
burner xp oder irgendwie so hieß dieses ding
genau das ding hatte ich dann immer also die webseite sieht aber auch aus wie 2004 oder
Cd burner xp
Auszeichnungen.
Hilfe und Fragen.
Guck mal, ob es einen Wikipedia-Eintrag dazu gibt.
Wann gab es denn da die letzte Version?
Aktuelle Version.
2019 immerhin.
So, dann habe ich das Ding danach benutzt.
Screenshots.
Genau, so sah das Ding aus.
CD Burner XP.
Sonst hier Sachen tracken und droppen und brennen.
Und erinnert sich noch jemand an die ersten Brenner-Generationen,
wo das Brennen der CD abkacken konnte, wenn du deinen Rechner zu sehr benutzt hast?
Buffer Under Run.
Oder, nee, wie hieß das?
Out of Buffer oder irgendwie sowas.
Da war die CD geschrottet,
wenn du deinen Rechner zu sehr benutzt hast.
Das war richtiger,
richtiger Schrott.
Naja, so, jetzt komm mal fertig.
Guck mal, da ist die berüchtigte AOL-CD.
Nur 499 DM.
dabei, also in Form von Michael.
Und die, da kann man kostenlos für einen Monat oder für 50 Stunden,
danach hast du ein Abo an der Backe,
für ein halbes Jahr kostenlos das Ganze testen.
Dann kann man einfach gucken, ob der Dienst was für einen ist,
ob man zum Beispiel diesen ganzen Wetter oder ob man Nachrichten,
ob man sowas braucht.
Man kann aber auch gucken, welche anderen Provider es gibt.
Und es gibt ja auch Dienste im Internet,
die werden wir in Schriftform auch verschicken.
Da kommt nachher noch die Anschrift.
Vielleicht schon mal Papier und Stift bereithalten.
Damals hast du noch dahin geschrieben mit einem frankierten Rückumschlag
und hast dann eine Liste mit Anbietern und sowas gekriegt.
Und auch danach bei uns im Internet gibt es Dienste, wo man die Postleitzahl angeben kann.
Und da kriegt man aufgelistet, welche Provider in der Nähe sind.
Das ist ja auch für die Telefongebühren wichtig.
Jetzt hast du da eben gesagt, wir haben also eine ganze Menge Angebote in Zeitungen und so weiter.
Wir haben diese CD-ROMs gesehen, wo die Programme drauf sind.
Man muss aber grundsätzlich, glaube ich, dazu noch etwas sagen. Man läuft eventuell in eine ganz böse Falle hinein. Wenn Sie sich ein solches Programm holen, was Sie kostenlos mitgeliefert bekommen und installieren das und melden sich bei diesem Provider an für 50 oder 100 oder 300 Stunden kostenlosen Zugang, müssen Sie dennoch Ihre Kreditkartennummer hinterlegen.
und es ist bei manchen gar nicht so einfach, wieder rauszukommen, sich wieder abzumelden.
Da sind einige dabei, die sind nicht so lieb und sagen, der hat jetzt den Test in Anspruch genommen und jetzt darf er wieder raus.
Da muss man Kündigungszeiten einhalten, da muss man schriftlich kündigen,
da muss man aufpassen, dass man nicht wirklich über den Löffel barbiert wird, weil die einfach weiter danach abrechnen.
Genau, genau. Das hat AOL damals auch so gemacht.
Sie lesen das Kleingedruckte, holen sich erst die Geschäftsbedingungen, gucken da genau rein,
damit sie nicht hinterher zu ihrem kostenlosen Test mehr zahlen müssen.
Mich wundert es, dass Sie nichts zu Call-by-Call-Anbietern erzählen.
Wir haben aber auch eine Möglichkeit, wenn wir Windows 95 haben, brauchen wir sowas.
Wenn wir 98 haben, da ist ja ein Explorer dabei. Wie geht denn das da? Kann ich da direkt rein?
Theoretisch ja. Bei Windows 98 gibt es auch so eine Provider-Auswahl.
Das heißt, so einige der Internet-Provider hier in Deutschland haben sich dort Buttons gekauft
oder durch Verträge, sowas abgeschlossen, dass man sich direkt dann dort einwählen kann.
Wenn man natürlich einen anderen Provider nehmen möchte, was eigentlich vielfach der Fall ist,
gerade hier in Deutschland, muss man natürlich den etwas schwierigen Weg halt über die CDs gehen.
Oder man ruft einen Provider an, so eine Hotline und sagt, schick mir mal eine CD, ich will das mal ausprobieren.
Okay, wie schwer ist denn das, so etwas zu installieren? Ich lege die CD rein, die startet sich automatisch.
Aus welchem Jahr das ist? 1999?
anfangen.
Ja, man muss die Zugangsdaten haben.
Das heißt also, sprich, bei den normalen Providern halt sein Passwort
und seinen Namen.
Bei der Telekom
musstest du
so ein richtig langes
Teil eingeben. Warte mal, mal gucken, ob ich das
noch finde. Telekom
Mitbenutzer
Kennung
Die Online-als-DFÜ-Verbindung
genau format für genau format für benutzername ist zwölfstellige anschlusskennung danach die
vierstellige oder wie auch immer die online nummer genau das rautezeichen musste man nur
machen wenn die theon an nummer weniger als zwölf stellen hat dann muss man die mit benutzerkennung
ohne führende nullen eingeben du musstest dir das selbst noch zusammenbauen damals das ist so
richtig pp gar gewesen
guck mal hier gibt es sogar noch
jeder hatte da hat ein schönes beispiel für anschlusskennung die online
nummer raut 001 also genau so sah das dann so ein langes ding hast du als benutzer namen gebraucht
was du dir selbst irgendwie zusammen basteln musste ist sehr weird das zeug
vor nummer natürlich die angewählt werden muss ja und das war's wenn ich jetzt keine
kreditkarte habe kann ich mich da auch testweise anwenden es gibt welche wo das geht wir haben
einen Provider, zum Beispiel das ist GermanyNet, der ist völlig kostenlos. Dort kann man sich
also einfach anmelden und ist ein Mitglied. Nachteil ist, man muss sich dort etwas mehr
Werbung gefallen lassen. Das heißt, wenn man jetzt von einem Land ins nächste, ich
drücke es mal ganz grob aus, wechselt, bekommt man eine Werbeseite eingeblendet. Ja. Und
den kann man auch nicht abbrechen, sondern die muss man sich anmelden. Gut, aber das
wäre vielleicht ein Tipp, wenn jemand nur mal reinriechen will und nur mal probieren
will, Mensch, ich möchte mal ein Gefühl bekommen, ist das was für mich oder nicht?
Da lässt man sich eben mal ein bisschen Werbung gefallen, man kann nicht die Augen zumachen.
Ja, die Frage ist halt, wie ist es mit der Bandbreite? Ist mir das schnell genug? Muss ich nicht zu lange warten auf Informationen? Das ist ja immer auch so ein Thema. Man wird ja dann auch direkt ein bisschen gierig und möchte die Informationen möglichst schnell haben. Man will nicht stundenlang warten.
Ich glaube, wir sollten jetzt mal rüber zu Wolfgang Back schauen. Der steht wieder bei den Zuschauern.
Ich glaube, damals gab es noch keine Adblocker.
Chat.
Also, ich glaube, das war noch nicht.
Ich bin mir gar nicht sicher, ob es für Netscape Navigator Add-ons gab.
Oder Plugins.
... jemand Erfahrung gemacht mit so kostenlosen Zugängen.
Ja, also ich habe hier totale Anfänger hier zu befragen.
Die verdienen zwar alle ihr Geld damit, scheinbar.
Sie sind Programmierer, machen jeden Tag Internet.
Ja, jeden Tag.
Ich mache jeden Tag Internet.
Das ist für Sie wahrscheinlich kein Thema, was wir da besprochen haben.
Ich finde es wichtig, vielen Leuten das so nahe zu bringen, weil ich auch täglich gefragt werde, wie komme ich ins Internet.
Von daher habe ich vielen Freunden auch erzählt, sie sollten heute...
Na, was meint ihr in Wasser programmiert? 1999.
Stimmt, Basic. Microsoft Visual Basic oder sowas.
Java, Delphi, Pascal.
Ja, C wäre so das Standardding, aber wahrscheinlich ist es bestimmt Visual Basic oder sowas.
Mal zugucken.
Und können Sie auch noch sagen, was Sie machen im Internet?
Informationen hauptsächlich beschaffen über neue Programmiertools, neue Programmiersprachen.
Und dann programmieren Sie auch selbst fürs Internet oder für andere Programme?
Fürs Internet.
Mit Java jetzt immer mehr.
Ah, Java.
Ich finde es cool, dass er das nochmal gesagt hat, aber das ist doch Bescheid.
java
fürs internet also ins internet ist in aller munde wie oft wie oft macht das am tag also
ganze tag eingeschaltet oder wir haben einen linux server der welt sich auto
Hoho, der richtige Hackerman, Alter!
Oder ist einem das so beigefallen?
Oder brauchte man da Freunde, die man gefragt hat, damit es überhaupt funktioniert hat?
Also bei mir ist es relativ unkompliziert gewesen.
Ich habe mir damals eine CD besorgt und die installiert und damit war die Sache vergessen.
Da war also nichts Kompliziertes dabei.
Und dass man sich natürlich dann erstmal im Internet zurechtfindet, das braucht natürlich seine Zeit.
Und machen Sie es heute noch mit Modem?
Ja.
Und wie schnell ist das Modem?
Das ist ein 28-8er Modem.
Oh, die Zeit ist um.
Sie kommt ja ganz schnell etwas zeigen und zwar haben wir hier unsere Informationen so können sie die abrufen schauen sich das an
Briefmarke drauf und da stecken sie dann die Anschrift an uns einen DIN A5 Umschlag hinein gefaltet auch mit einer Mark 50
frankiert und bitte Büchersendungen draufschreiben dann bekommt die Information zu dieser Sendung so und dann sollten die Leute sich wieder anmelden
für unsere Sendung die hier zu buch sein wollten
Es gibt also die Möglichkeit hier
Platz zu nehmen Internet ist gefragt dann Tschüss bis zum nächsten Mal
Ja.
Jetzt wissen wir Bescheid.
Weißt du, ich will jetzt auch mal gucken,
was hatte Debian Version
History. Ich will mal gucken, was der Typ
damals für eine Linux, für eine
Debian, der hat bestimmt Debian benutzt damals.
Dieser Fisch, danke schön für den Sub.
Debian Releases.
die waren bestimmt nicht so top aktuell
ja
Debian Ham hat er wahrscheinlich damals
gehabt auf seiner Kiste
Suse
meinst du ja Suse das kann sein
Suse war in Deutschland saubeliebt
Suse
Linux Wikipedia
lass uns mal kurz gucken
Nee, nicht OpenSUSE.
SUSE Linux Enterprise.
Nee.
SUSE.
Nicht Enterprise.
SUSE Linux.
Version.
History.
Aber OpenSUSE gibt es doch.
Okay, findet man nicht mehr.
2005, Keckweight.
Ich hatte damals auch
Suse auf irgendwie...
Es waren so blaue...
Vier blaue CDs oder sowas.
Ja.
Slackware-User?
Ich weiß nicht. Ich glaub nicht.
Slackware war auch damals
wahrscheinlich ziemlich Nische.
Debian 1.0 gab es nie.
Das ist mir auch neu.
Warum denn das nicht?
Debian 1.1 gab es aber.
Ah, guck mal da.
History.
Copy Link.
Ah.
Moment.
Suse war irgendwann mal Slackware-based?
Wusste ich gar nicht.
99.
Hier.
Suse Linux
hatte der wahrscheinlich.
Eurex auch nie gehört.
Ne, hier.
Suse Linux, das da.
Hat er wahrscheinlich gehabt, irgendwie sowas.
6.0, 6.1,
6.3.
Irgendwie sowas hat er auf seinem Server
wahrscheinlich gehabt damals.
Aber 1999 schon Linux-Server am Start zu haben, der war richtig vorne mit dabei.
Mein Linux, die allererste Linux-Version, die released wurde, war glaube ich 1991.
Glaube ich.
Ja.
1991.
0.01. September 1991.
Suse oder Redhead? Du meinst heute eindeutig Redhead.
Suse kommt mir nicht ins Haus.
Oder in die Tüte.
Tim wohnt in einem Wasserturm.
Warum auch nicht, ne?
Was haben wir hier?
Homelab. Einfach mal ein komplettes Rack voll mit Dingern.
Achso, das ist Techno-Tim.
Okay, vergesst es, Leute.
Vergesst es, Leute.
95, 99% der Hardware ist einfach nur da, um sich selbst zu verwalten.
Die Videos von ihm sind immer ein bisschen pepeger in der Richtung.
Und wenn ich frag, warum hat er diesen ganzen Shit, um sich selbst zu verwalten?
Ja, die Dinger sind cool.
Da habe ich auch einen bei mir im Rack drin.
Einfach, weil ich die so nice finde, diese Durchführungspanels mit dem Besen drin.
Aber sehr ordentlich.
Das ist cool.
ein intel-nook-cluster wahrscheinlich für sein komisches kubernetes zeug wo er irgendwie drei
kubernetes cluster hat die sich selbst verwalten
Das war nicht genug. Ich habe eine ganze Wand von Technik.
Das ist mein Home-Labs.
Fühlt man sich wie ein Computergenie.
Das stimmt wohl.
90er PC Momente, die heutige Kids nie erleben werden.
Festplatten defragmentieren war das Highlight unserer Tage.
Naja, so das Highlight war das nicht.
Wir haben stundenlang auf...
Ist das AI Stimme?
...den Fortschrittsbalken gestarrt und wenn er endlich voll war, ein echtes Erfolgserlebnis.
Nein, das ist AI-Crap-Video.
Haben wir ansonsten noch?
Was war mit Karsten los?
Ja, das haben wir uns schon immer gefragt.
Wiesenkellner verrät sein Gehalt.
Also ganz ehrlich, das ist auch was,
würde ich mir nie im Leben geben.
Hast viel zu viel Kontakt mit Leuten und permanent Stress.
Guck mal mal,
was der Wiesenkellner macht.
Ich krieg langsam echt Hunger.
Ach ja, Leute, heute ist wieder traditionelles Essen
angesagt am Sonntag.
Was gibt's heute?
Es gibt zwei Varianten. Nein, kein Lachs mit Nudel.
Es gibt... Was ist die Alternative
zu Lachs mit Nudel?
Pizza?
ne döner 13 avocado toast ein spaghetti bolognese tomatensoße genau
wenn es keine wenn es keine nudeln mit lachs gibt dann bolognese
So, dann gucken wir mal, was der Wiesenkellner so verdient.
Ihr müsst den Leuten schon ordentlich was bezahlen, das macht jetzt doch keiner freiwillig.
Also wirklich, Pause haben wir nicht.
Gestern hatte ich gar keine Pause, gestern haben wir den ganzen Tag gar nichts gegessen.
Du hast mir nichts gegeben.
Ich hab dir Ruinat Rosé gegeben.
Also wirklich, Pause haben wir nicht.
Gestern hatte ich gar keine Pause, gestern haben wir den ganzen Tag gar nichts gegessen.
Du hast mir nichts gegeben.
Ich hab dir Ruinat Rosé gegeben.
Wenn uns ein Zettel verloren geht, dann haben wir erstmal das Geld auch verloren.
Wenn ich jetzt keinen Trinker kriegen würde, würde ich den Job glaube ich nicht machen.
Ob da wirklich... Die Leute, die kennen ja da auch nichts. Die versuchen da bestimmt auch zu bescheißen.
Hi, ich bin der Yannick, bin 25 Jahre alt und Bedienung auf dem Oktoberfest.
Und heute zeige ich euch eins der größten Geheimnisse. Wie viel verdient ein Wiesenkellner?
Hallo. Wie fit bist du?
Nicht fit, ehrlich gesagt. Ich habe wieder nur 4,5 Stunden geschlafen.
Oh, ist aber wenig.
Ich bin um halb 3 gestern. Aber so ist es halt, muss ich durch.
Sehr viele von den Kollegen kommen ja von außerhalb, nicht aus München.
Die müssen dann erstmal für die 16 Tage oder so lange wie die Wiesn geht erstmal eine Wohnung finden und Miete zahlen.
Das ist ein riesen Kostenfaktor für andere. Da habe ich echt Glück, dass es bei mir nicht so ist.
Ich bin jetzt noch zu Hause, ziehe aber aus. Da schaue ich, dass ich meine Miete plus meine Studiengebühren, die noch dazukommen, einfach mit meinem Wiesnverdienst jetzt erstmal größtenteils decke, damit ich da bis zur nächsten Wiesn keine Sorgen habe.
Ich habe so überhaupt keinerlei Verlangen danach, auf das Oktoberfest zu gehen.
Also, juckt mich so überhaupt nicht.
Was ich brauche, um den Tag zu starten, ist prinzipiell eigentlich nur meine Lederhose.
Das ist natürlich das Wichtigste.
Plus mein Kellner.
Also das nächste, wie ich dem Oktoberfest jemals gekommen bin, ich bin da mal dran
vorbeigelaufen.
Da war gerade Aufbau.
So, das war's.
Geldbeutel, meine Weste, die ist vom Zelt, die kriegen wir vom Zelt erst mal gestellt,
müssen sie aber abkaufen.
So, jetzt muss ich mich erst mal umziehen.
Bis gleich.
Ich kann es immer ein bisschen schlecht einschätzen, wie der Tag so läuft, vor allem an so einem
Sonntag.
Kann jetzt sein, dass jetzt mittags total viele kommen zum Essen, Trinken und kann aus
seiner Sicht erstmal leer ist, bis mittags, nachmittags, wenn sie vielleicht den Biergarten
setzen.
Das ist mein Zelt, in dem ich jetzt arbeite, seit zwei Jahren.
Morgen, hallo.
Alles klar?
Das ist ein Zelt?
Das ist mein Bereich.
Das sieht aus wie eine Halle.
Also die vier Tische und die vier Tische in der Mitte.
Jetzt gucke ich erstmal kurz, welche Reservierungen kommen, ob jemand mittags kommt.
Heute steht für mich an, erstmal Bereich putzen, sauber machen, gucken, dass alles soweit ready ist für den Tag.
Dann hoffe ich, dass meine Teamkollegen rechtzeitig kommen, falls es wirklich brennt und eng wird,
dass ich nicht alleine hier drin stehe in meinem Bereich.
Und sonst natürlich Spaß haben und hoffentlich guten Umsatz und gutes Geld machen.
Ich hab ein bisschen Stress, weil einfach alles gewischt haben muss.
Jetzt kommen auch schon die Leute rein, das Festzeitgelände.
Und ich weiß, wann halt die ersten Gäste kommen.
Okay, ab 9 Uhr wird da schon Bier gesoffen.
Meine Herausforderung ist definitiv erstmal fit zu bleiben, nicht ultrakrank zu werden.
Drumherum komme ich eigentlich nicht, kommt eigentlich fast keiner hier als Bedienung
auf der Wiese, wenn man einfach zwischen so vielen Menschen ist.
Man schläft wenig, das Immunsystem ist eh geschwächt, man isst nie gescheit.
Soll ich noch ein paar machen oder wie sieht's aus?
Das Besteckgeld gibt's bei uns, weil die schon so geliefert werden.
Also auf anderen Festen, da müssen wir das selber machen.
Macht mir auch nicht so Spaß, da zahl ich lieber ein bisschen Besteckgeld und hab die
schon erledigt.
Du musst die nur auf den Teller tun.
Servus!
Ein Maß Apfelschorle und ein Maß Bier, oder?
Jawoll!
15,80!
Krass!
Alter!
15,80 krass alter
Ich poniere das auf dem Gerät, krieg die Zettel raus,
geb die ab, krieg dafür meine Getränke und dann kassier ich die Gäste dann ab.
Das heißt ich muss nie in die Vorkasse gehen, nichts abkaufen,
was für uns natürlich entspannter ist. Da bin ich auch ganz froh drum.
Darf ich es nicht vertauschen? Mach es nicht so schaumig.
Sonst gebe ich dem Kind das Bier. Schau mal.
So, schau es mal.
Wolltest du noch Strohhalme haben?
Ich werde hier auf der Wiese nach Umsatz bezahlt.
Das heißt, so viel, wie viele Sachen ich verkaufe hier im Zelt,
da kriege ich prozentual davon eine Umsatzbeteiligung, die natürlich noch versteuert wird.
Wie viel kostet eine Flasche Wasser? 10 Euro?
Das ist über 15.000, 16.000 Umsatz als Dreierteam.
Würde ich sagen, war ein sehr guter Tag.
Jetzt sind wir bei 77,80 für alles zusammen.
Krasser Scheiß, 77 Euro für...
Was haben die gehabt?
Na gut, da wird noch was zu essen dabei gekommen sein, aber das ist schon echt heftig teuer.
77 Euro.
Dafür kann ich eine ganze Woche fressen gehen.
Ja, guckt, es ist ja auch nicht, als hätten die viel gehabt.
Ein paar Pommes frites.
Und dann weiß ich nicht, was man da sonst noch so nimmt.
Wenn Gäste so Gutscheine haben, dann habe ich die, ich habe ja einen Gesamtbetrag vom Tisch.
Und dann ziehe ich die sozusagen ab.
Und dann gibt es noch einen Restbetrag, den der Gast noch zahlen muss.
Wenn er natürlich noch ein Trinkgeld geben möchte, noch auf den Betrag davor.
Weil da sieht man jetzt gleich, ich ziehe die ab.
Am Ende sind da nur noch 6 Euro drauf.
Und dann passiert es oft, dass die Gäste sagen, ja, dann auf die 6 Euro gebe ich 10%.
Aber eigentlich waren es ja...
Ich würde da überhaupt nichts geben, wenn das so teuer ist.
So, jetzt sind wir da weg. Jetzt bleiben noch 12,10 Euro.
Das machst du mit Karte, gell?
Passt, danke dir.
Ich habe gerade auf einer Rechnung von ein bisschen mehr als 75 Euro knapp 8 Euro Trinkgeld bekommen.
Und das ist völlig in Ordnung für mich.
10% für einen Service, wenn die Gäste zufrieden waren, ist bei uns auch so die Regel, sage ich jetzt mal.
Ich würde überhaupt kein Trinkgeld bezahlen, das ist schon teuer genug.
Wasser 11,50.
Es ist jetzt ja auch nicht, dass man da unbedingt wegen der Atmosphäre hingeht, oder?
da ist es einfach nur laut und stickig und ich verstehe es nicht.
Es leuchtet nicht ein.
Ich hatte mal eine Situation, vier Teil jeder waren es, glaube ich, die haben hier mittags alle ein Weißbier getrunken,
hatten noch so viel über, haben gesagt, die gehen nur kurz eine rauchen und dann waren sie weg.
Und dann sind wir auf knapp 40 Euro sitzen geblieben.
Wenn das natürlich öfters passiert, ist schlecht, so richtig schlecht für uns, weil wir einfach das Geld verlieren.
Ich habe jetzt 14 Bier, die kann ich noch ganz gut tragen.
Ich mach's so zwischendrin normal im Fitness, aber ich mach's jetzt nicht extra für die Wiesentraining.
Boah, da musst du aber ordentlich was balancieren.
Dem kann man zumindest nicht vorwerfen, dass er nichts arbeiten würde.
Ich glaube, das ist eine verdammt harte Zeit hier.
Jetzt haben wir's.
C.
Jawohl.
Der Max, mein Teampartner, der hat mich zu dem Job gebracht.
Der war schon zwei Jahre vorher auf der Wiesn und das hat sich ergeben.
Wenn Platz frei geworden ist in einem Team, dann meint der, ob ich nicht auch Lust habe,
habe ich natürlich sofort angenommen.
Toast, Toast, Toast, Toast, Toast, Toast, Toast, Toast, Toast, Toast, Toast, Toast.
Jetzt muss man auf die Uhr gucken. Jetzt ist 16.30 Uhr.
Es ist vielleicht zeitlich Halbzeit, aber jetzt wird es definitiv nochmal richtig anstrengend.
Krass, Halbzeit. Wie 15 Stunden am Tag, oder?
Also ich würde sagen, 30 Prozent habe ich geschafft von der Anstrengung.
Jetzt wird es nochmal hart abends. Also wirklich Pause haben wir nicht.
Gestern hatte ich gar keine Pause. Gestern haben wir den ganzen Tag gar nichts gegessen.
Heute ging es mittags, deswegen konnte ich mal kurz was essen.
aber wirklich pause hat man nicht
ist das ganze putzen und so ist das heißt es ist ja die sind schon
vorbezahlt okay was kostet so ein menü knapp 900 euro
Alter! Ich wollte gerade sagen, das ist bestimmt teuer, aber...
Wow!
89 Euro!
Das sind ein paar Chicken Wings.
Ein bisschen Leberkäs.
Das ist nicht nur für die Platte 8, da gibt es noch mehr.
Das ist soweit in Ordnung, bin ich auch zufrieden mit.
Wenn der Abend jetzt noch gut läuft, dann ist das ein super Tag gewesen.
Die Abendstimmung ist immer gut, vor allem wenn das Licht gedimmt wird,
die Partylichter gehen an, die Band geht hoch, die Leute gehen auf die Bänke.
Das ist natürlich immer cool.
Es gibt dann natürlich nochmal einen richtigen extra Push am Ende für die letzten drei, vier Stunden.
Wenn man schon zehn Stunden in den Knochen hat, dass man sagt, man ist noch ein bisschen motiviert, das jetzt durchzuziehen.
Also die wichtigste Eigenschaft ist...
Ich hätte da so keinen Bock drauf, Alter.
Ich muss belastbar sein, sympathisch sein,
mit den Gästen kommunizieren können.
Und nicht wegen Kleinigkeiten hochgehen oder gestresst sein.
Das bringt hier gar nichts. Das macht alles nur noch viel schlimmer.
Oh, sorry. Hast du den schon gegeben?
Er ist mitgenommen. Ich sehe 2 Flaschen.
Nein, Ruinard Rosé hab ich dir gegeben.
Du hast mir nichts gegeben. Ich hab dir Ruinard Rosé gegeben.
verloren geht oder der Drucker spinnt und das Papier nicht druckt oder wir eins auf
dem Weg verlieren, dann haben wir erstmal das Geld auch verloren, weil das wurde uns
ja abgezogen, das haben wir gebucht, können es aber nicht abkassieren, weil das ja der
Gast nie bekommen hat. Das wird ja kein Mensch zahlen, wenn er das nicht kriegt. Trotzdem
ist es bei uns weg, somit bleiben wir erstmal drauf sitzen.
Alter, und es ist wahrscheinlich noch nicht mal guter Champagner.
Wir vertrauen uns hier alle und am Ende hat es ja meine Kollegin auch gesehen, dass ich
den Cellier gegeben habe, nur die hat ihn zu schnell weggetan.
Deswegen haben wir uns dann auch schnell geeinigt, dass ich das trotzdem mitnehmen darf.
Erwartet, dass ich mitfeiere, wirkt jetzt erstmal nicht.
Trotzdem gibt es Gäste, die waren jetzt schon öfters hier.
Da gibt es viele, die dann auch sagen, ja komm, du hast uns jetzt alle ein Bier gebracht.
Bring doch für euch auch mal eins mit als Team und wir stoßen alle mal an.
Da würde ich aber ehrlich gesagt versuchen, möglichst wenig zu saufen an den ihrer Stelle.
Weil du bist super kreislaufmäßig dabei, musst noch schaffen.
Wenn du da besoffen bist, kriegst du ja nichts mehr auf die Reihe.
Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, T
vorbei, weil ich muss ja seriös bleiben. Ich bin auch seriös in meinem Beruf, aber gehört natürlich schon dazu.
Das wäre ja Folter für mich, wenn ich die Musik da ein paar Stunden ertragen müsste.
Ich bin 16 Tage lang jeden Tag von morgens um 8 oder 10 bis Mitternacht da.
Jeden Tag.
Dann ist man froh, aber locker nicht.
Ich bin jetzt schon tot, das ist der zweite Tag.
Wenn ich jetzt keinen Trinker kriegen würde, würde ich den Job glaube ich nicht machen.
Letztendlich kann man ja alles am Ende auf die Stunde rechnen.
Ich weiß ja, wie viel Zeit ich hier verbringe.
Und mit meinem Verdienst am Ende würde ich dann, wenn man das Trinkgeld abzieht,
auch wirklich auf einen schlechten Stundenlohn kriegen.
Aber für sich diese harte Arbeit und die kompletten 16 Tage,
abgeschottet von allem anderen, definitiv nicht lohnwürdig.
Also es sind insgesamt 975, wenn ihr uns ein Trinkgeld geben wollt.
975, da bist du ordentlich Kohle los hier auf dem Oktoberfest.
Der Betrag und am Ende bleiben 225 übrig.
Danke euch.
Merci. Ich hoffe, ihr hattet Spaß.
Danke dir.
Energie ist wenig.
Also ich bin bei 2 Prozent.
Ich brauch jetzt dringend mal sechs, sieben Stunden Schlaf.
Wir sind jetzt auch durch.
Ich freue mich, wenn jetzt der Bereich mal sauber ist
und dann können wir abrechnen und nach Hause gehen.
Schauen wir jetzt mal.
16 Stunden. Krass. Einfach ein doppelter Arbeitstag in einem.
Tagesabschluss rausgelassen. Letztendlich haben wir 16.179 Euro Umsatz, wo natürlich noch die Umsatzsteuer weggerechnet werden muss.
Unsere Umsatzbeteiligung kriegen wir auf den Nettoumsatz und das sind 9,5 Prozent. Den ganzen Betrag muss man natürlich durch drei teilen, weil wir ein dreier Team sind.
Trinkgeld sind von dem Ganzen dann 1040, das wir steuerfrei natürlich überwiesen kriegen.
Wir drei, das heißt 1040 durch drei und das kriegen wir dann am Ende der Wiesn überwiesen als Trinkgeld.
Zum Wohle!
Ich habe letztes Jahr rund 6600 Euro brutto verdient. Das war meine Umsatzbeteiligung.
Da muss ich erstmal schön Steuer drauf bezahlen.
Natürlich noch die Steuer weg, das Steckgeld weg, meine Essenspauschale für Personalgetränke und Personalessen.
Und dann komme ich dann am Ende auf ca. 5.400 Euro, die ich überwiesen bekommen habe.
Und dann ist natürlich noch ein anderer Teil das Trinkgeld. Das kriege ich steuerfrei.
In der Kombination bin ich dann letztes Jahr...
7.000 Euro, dafür bist du...
Auf knapp 12.500 Euro.
Ja, dafür bist du halt dead nach zweieinhalb Wochen.
ist aber halt schon mal ordentlich,
gerade wenn man studiert und so,
schon ordentlich mal
einen Monat oder einen halben Monat
so viel Kohle.
Aber das ist halt auch sauanstrengend.
Ich bin auf jeden Fall zufrieden heute,
es lief gut, für das das ein Sonntag war,
es war trotzdem schönes Wetter, wir sind drin im Zelt.
So wie alles gelaufen ist,
kann es gerne weiterlaufen die nächsten 14 Tage
und dann bin ich sehr zufrieden
und gehe gut nach Hause
mit einem guten Gefühl.
Torst, Torst, Torst, Torst, Torst, Torst, Torst, Torst, Torst, Torst, Torst, Torst, Torst, Torst.
Tja.
Chat.
Du bist ja noch Azubi, oder?
Der Wiesenkellner.
Oh.
So, Chat.
Ich geh jetzt was essen.
Ich hab Hunger.
Wir sehen uns.
Nächsten Stream.
Bis dann. Macht's gut.
See you.